Well, he is is he calling that it's morally justified and and
it it's legal to have an armed resistance against like Ethan's
wife, Hila? >> No. Not outside of a very specific
>> That's crazy. >> That's crazy. >> That's
crazy, chat. >> That's crazy, Chad. >> No, he's Where's
the code?
There's no >> There really isn't a code. There is no code.
It is just obvious what's >> What do you mean? Where's
the coded language?
Hello. Hello.
Hello.
How's it going, guys? How we doing today? How we doing? How we
feeling? How's it going? What's up? What's up? What's up? It's
Sunday night, guys. It's Sunday night and uh I'm witnessing I'm
witnessing an OP right now. Okay. In real time. In real time.
We're witnessing an OP. Okay. This is some crazy This is some
crazy [__] Dude. I actually don't. I actually don't.
I don't want to defend this. Okay. I don't I don't at all. God.
But here's the thing. When you start with a blatant lie that's
amplified by like a trillion people,
I have so little patience for anybody who goes, "Yeah, but like
really, why did he talk about Hila at all? Like why did he mention
he?" It's like, "Shut the up. Call out the liars first. Call
out the people who blew this out of proportion and then talk
about what the real criticism is." Okay? I'm so sick of everybody
going, "Yeah, well, but like, isn't there kind of a point there
that he mentioned healing?" Like a kind of heated situation and
and shut the up. Okay, what are you talking
>> Call out the people who blatantly lied. Asmin Gold,
Techone, whoever else covered this clip and just did no work
to go find any context at all. Well, actually, we'll go into
those cuz we're actually going to look at them and see if they
went and found context. I assume they didn't because of the clips
that are coming out from them. Okay,
>> dude.
It's crazy,
huh? It's wild. What's going on out here? Okay.
What are you little workout videos in the background? No, I'm
not I'm not doing it. But we'll we'll definitely be taking a
longer look into all this. Okay. Like, you can't just lie. You
can't just write fanfiction like this, right? >> And not
get called out. And if you participate in it, you need to say
what you did wrong. Stop participating the fanfiction and then
going, "Well, you know, I'm not going to say it was wrong and
I'm kind of going to like sort of make a different criticism."
No. Call out the people who are lying. Call out the people who
are lying. Make sure they know they're lying. >> If you
care about this kind of thing, okay? If you care about people
telling the truth, if you care about any of this at all, this
is what you should do. All
>> Uh, no. I haven't heard of that. Junarch. Nope. We're
uh, we might take a second to get started here. Give me a second.
Give me a second. Okay. Hey. Oh, I don't know if I could watch
this. The top the only thing on the subreddit right now is a
Fuentes low tier god clip. I don't know. I don't know if I can
watch that on Twitch right now. Okay. The truth in politics.
Now that's funny. It's not just politics though. It's like just
lying about like the exact thing that happened.
>> I feel like that's to me that was something I wanted
to do for politics a little bit was um go and show how people
lie to frame things incorrectly, right? Like I thought Biden
was too old, but I watched some of the Republican framings of
clips of him to make him look like scenile and it's like dude,
if you just look at the whole clip, like it's clear that that's
not really a problem here. Okay, LTG streams on Twitch though.
Yeah, but I don't know if he stream this on Twitch and I don't
know if this will be safe for Twitch. So, we'll have to we'll
have to wait a second and check it out. Let me start up the timers.
Let me get the timers going, guys.
4 hours. I'll reset the meters. We're going to be ready to go.
It's going to be a stream and a half. I'll hopefully be able
to get some people on uh to talk about this as well. I just love
to see what other people think about this because it's pretty
crazy to me. Okay, how people are lying. Okay, I just got a thousand
YouTube notifications at once or a thousand Yeah, Chrome notifications.
I need to shut my Chrome notifications off for YouTube on this
computer. Holy [__] that's actually so annoying.
Okay, God.
Holy Hold on. I need to watch I need to watch people soy about
the the actual clip. Okay, the actual clip as it came out. Oh,
>> Oh, what is that? What is that? What is that? Max the
Confessor, thank you for the five months. Thank you, Max. Welcome,
Max. Good to have you back on board. Okay, hold on. Let me find
the the actual first clip. Where is it at? Where is it at? Where
is it at? The [__] says that Ela Klein is a valid
military target. No repercussions. Notice how. Okay, very cleverly,
I'm just gonna I'm gonna point out all of my skitso theories.
All of my skitso. Okay, I'm I'm going to point it all out. Okay,
notice how this is not clipped in a way where you can go through
and watch the VOD. Notice how they've they've sliced the context
away, right? There's no way for you to go get context from this,
right? It's not a Twitch clip. It's not a Twitch clip that links
to a VOD. Why does it still say, "Oh, sorry. I'll get out of
Scavenger hunt channel or uh the category." Just chatting.
Cuz that's what we're doing. We're just chatting. Let me get
my music going again. But notice this is like very intentional
by the way that they do not want you to go and click through
and actually watch what was said, right? This is the 50-second
one that's floating around. Yes. Stale didn't remove this for
editorializing either. Curious. Apparently not. No. Apparently
that's all good now. Okay. I know LSF lets you put post clips
that are not from Twitch, but I'm saying it'd be far easier to
just post a Twitch clip, right? You can look it up if you need
more. I don't need more. I'm telling you that it is intentionally
done this way to paint a certain picture, okay? because they
don't want it to be easy for people to go do more.
Okay, obvious clear. >> They're DFLP, PFLP, or even former
FA
>> matter if they're DFLP, PFLP, or even former FATA militants.
Okay, it is perfectly legal, perfectly valid. And >> so
just to be clear, >> DLP, PFLP, or even former FA militants.
So that that is clipped in a way that makes it sound like oh
former militants would be like valid military targets, right?
But former here right there it's referring to former Fatah militants.
Fatah being the party that run that ran like all Palestinian
affairs for years. The party of Yaser Arafat, right? He's naming
militant groups. He's saying they can engage in violence. Even
if they're even if they're militant like terrorist groups, designated
terrorist groups, they could still engage in violence in the
West Bank against the Israeli military.
But a lot of think, oh, he's talking about former military members
being valid targets of something. And they have no if you trust
me, that's the immediate filter. If you don't know that he's
talking about Palestinian groups there, you should just walk
away from this clip. You shouldn't have an opinion. You're too
stupid to function, okay, in this environment. Which is not a
problem. Maybe you just don't have knowledge of this place, okay?
Maybe you live a totally different life. But if you don't know
what that means, shut the up. Walk away. Okay? Matter if they're
DFLP, PFLP, or even former FATA militants. Okay? It is perfectly
legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral. Okay? 100%. This
is not like a black and this is not a gray area. This is black
and white. Okay? It doesn't get more black and white than this.
Israel is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging in an apartheid,
which is a crime in and of itself. Israel is doing a genocide
in Gaza and an apartheid in the West Bank. Two crimes in and
of itself. >> Well, actually, I don't even know if I agree
with that. I'm just like, okay, I'm I'm understanding your premise.
Okay, I'm understanding. >> Every every type of armed resistance
against both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force
in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcasters
like uh wife that participate in the Israelians. Doesn't matter
if Oh, that's weird how that cuts. Okay.
So, what Hassan's doing there. So, that sounds that sounds like
you could make it like pretty bad, right? Like, oh, doesn't matter.
Oh, they're they're just valid military targets, right? Like
I almost understand with the way this is edited how somebody
could come to this conclusion now. You should immediately from
the editing, from all of the warning signs here, you should immediately
know, oh, well, this is this is weird. I don't something weird's
going on here. Okay.
Unfortunately, we're getting to the point where I hate Hassan.
I have no idea if he's talking He talks about the legal consequences
of this and stuff like, "Oh, it's all legal." I assume he's just
wrong because he's a Okay. I assume it's he's just wrong on like
everything he says about
But I when I hear Hassan now, when I hear Hassan said something,
I feel like I need to go confirm it because people just want
to lie about this guy. There's like so much incentive to just
lie about this guy for no reason. He is technically I'm sure
there's like a lot of technical minutiae you could get into here
around the legalities that that would be like kind of interesting
for people very invested in this stuff, right? But listen from
there I went and clipped the full thing. I went got a time stamp.
I clipped the full thing. I noticed that there wasn't a time
stamp listed anywhere. When all relevant asked for a time stamp,
he got just the full Hassan VOD.
Okay. Do we really give Hassan the grace when he gives it to
literally no one? You operate the way you want to operate in
the world, alias reign. I think there are so many valid things
to criticize Hassan for. Why would I just lie about the things
he's saying? There's so many actually valid things that he's
done bad that you can complain about and say Hassan's a person.
Hassan's a commentator. Hassan's a right. Yeah, you shouldn't.
It's not that you can't Ozel. In fact, you can, but you shouldn't.
You shouldn't. You should be above that. You should be above
their conduct. Okay, that's how it is. So, let's listen to the
whole thing. But it shows the thinking >> like any kind
of violence. >> So he's watching a a documentary on the
West Bank. Okay. Armed settlers and segregation inside the West
Bank. So he's always he's always within this context. Okay. Of
watching a documentary on armed violence and armed settlers in
the West Bank. Okay. Keep watching. >> Is that Israeli
settlers
or the the Israeli military experiences in the West
>> Yes. Is what people are soying out about. is literally
legal. Okay. It is legal resistance against an occupying military
force. I cannot
I cannot repeat this enough. Occupying military force. So he's
saying armed settlers going into the West Bank and and forming
settlements doing violence. Uh violence back to them is legal.
Uh if you're part of the occupying military force, violence in
in a if they're illegally occupying some area, right, which Israel
does,
then you are a valid target of >> Just like any kind of
violence, any kind of violence that the Israeli occupying force
experiences in the Gaza Strip is actually once again totally
legal and totally moral resistance by the Palestinians. Doesn't
matter if they're the Al Axa Brigade. Doesn't matter if they're
a part of the Palestinian Islamic Jihad. Doesn't matter if they're
DFLP, PFLP, or even former Fata militants.
Okay. So, that part where a bunch of morons think he's talking
about former militants being valid targets of He's saying, "I
don't care if they look like white people. I don't care if they
look like white people in a real army uniform getting bombed
by terrorists who are wearing a who are wearing a towel on their
head, okay? And and some mask covering their face. I don't give
a how evil they look to you. These Palestinian militants who
are doing violence, it is still moral, right? It doesn't matter
how nice the Israelis look. It doesn't look how e It doesn't
matter how evil the Palestinians look. Doesn't matter how matter
how evil their label is. Violence from the Palestinians against
the occupying military force is justified and legal is his argument.
Okay? Now remember that when he's saying even these evil groups,
okay, even these really bad groups, they can still do that violence.
Okay? It is perfectly legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral.
Okay? 100%. This is not like a black and this is not a gray area.
This is black and white. Okay? It doesn't get more black and
white than this. Israel is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging
in an apartheid.
Nope. This isn't what he's saying. It's not what we would say.
John Smoken, I think legal is fair, but I'd argue against the
moral point. I think if you think it's morally justified to
um to actually do violence to a woman who's in an Israeli like
IDF vehicle who's not really participating, who's a secretary,
if they captured like Ela Klein and did like any kind of vi that's
you're probably wrong, right? I feel like you're just wrong there
and you can disagree at this point, but anyway, sorry, I'll back
it up just a little >> More black and white than this.
Israel is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging in an apartheid,
which is a crime in and of itself. Israel is doing a genocide
in Gaza and an apartite in the West Bank. Two crimes in and of
itself. And every
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these raids. The violence that the pal So this is furthering.
Okay. It's continuing on from I don't care if you think these
people are good. If they are participating in this, they are
also valid targets. >> Palestinians
engage in in an act of resistance against this illegal occupying
force is literally legal, definitionally legal. Okay. >> Uh
wait, why isn't she technically contributing to the harm of Gaza?
She might be contributing to the harm, but he's not saying you
can target people who contribute to the to harm in Gaza. He is
saying people in if you are in Gaza as a part of this force that
is actively harming and participating in the the oppression of
these people then you are a valid military target
in the West Bank in the Gaza Strip in either one of those places
you would be a valid military target. If you are actively participating
in this in this military or in settling illegal settlements the
whole time he is talking about only in the West Bank only in
the Gaza Strip is clear as day. Do not link come vampire in my
chat, Matt Slice. But thank you for contributing. Okay, I don't
care about what Destiny is saying on this. Destiny will just
lie about things here. He will just write fanfiction with Dan.
The only goal they have is to lie.
It's actually pointless to engage with them. They are just liars.
That's it. It's just the truth. Straight up. It doesn't matter
that they look to be in garb that makes you think that they're
in the right. Okay. >> Yes. Bison's talking about the optics
of this that like, oh, we've been and like I don't even agree
with all the he's saying, right? But he's talking about the optics
of this. He's talking about how if they're wearing these like
headscarfves and and and they look like they're evil terrorists,
okay? Even if they look like this, that's still okay for them
to defend their homes. It's okay for them to defend their land.
No, it's dishonestly clipped, Vin. It's dishonestly clipped because
there's so much context around it to show exactly what he's talking
about. Like it's in the context of a documentary, a documentary
on armed settlements, armed settlers, right? It's in the context
of only the West Bank, only Gaza, that's all clipped out, right?
That's largely clipped out.
The only reason he mentions is to say it doesn't matter how nice
they are. Doesn't matter how nice they look. If they're a part
of the Israeli military and they are entering the Gaza Strip
or they're entering the West Bank, the the non whatever is it
C that's like 50/50 that's like mixed or something. If they're
if they're illegally entering the West Bank, if they're if they're
engaging in in occupation there, okay, they're a militarized
occupation, then it doesn't matter. I think they're a valid target.
I disagree with this point, by the way. But my my real issue
here is that I can't even agree or disagree with this point.
My real issue, okay,
is that people are painting this as Han calling for Hila Klein
to be in LA, which is insane.
Why? But why bring up Hila Klein at all? If you can't listen,
Potteros, leave. I just said why he brought up Hila Klein? It
has to do with his whole thing where he's saying it doesn't matter
how nice the Israelis look. It doesn't matter how evil the Palestinians
look. It matters. Okay? It matters that you say it's justified
for them to defend their land. So he's taking the nicest version
of somebody who didn't really engage, who actually went into
the West Bank as a part of a raid into Raala,
and he's saying that would even be a valid target. So he is he's
literally saying this is the nicest version of the IDF person,
the IDF member who's gone in there as a part of like a raid as
a part of like what he calls oppression. This is the nicest version.
Even if it's that guy versus some dude who's like a doppelganger
for Osama bin Laden who's got an AK-47 firing bullets at a car,
the the guy who looks like Osama bin Laden is justified. That's
what Hassan's trying to drive home here. That's why he uses Elil
Klein. There is he is in no way whatsoever driving violence or
or advocating for violence against Ela Klein. 0%. Yeah, just
continue to not engage because you're a cool actually. Just go.
Just go. You're too stupid to be here. Just leave or join up
in Discord. Okay. Join up in Discord. Make an argument. Guy knows
what he's doing when he brings her specifically up and you're
giving a ton of chair. No, I'm not. I'm not. I'm just listening
to what he's saying. I'm just listening to what he's saying and
interacting with what he's saying. If you want to say that, well,
the fact that he mentioned her at all means he's like kind of
uh pulling her in. Okay, sure. He's he's invoking like a a drama
that's been going on for months. Yes, he is not saying that you
can go hurt her by any measure. Which is why he explicitly says,
"No, that's not what that means at all." Yes, exactly. Ruminous,
you just have to you just have to engage in any way. But again,
I already said I have no patience for the who are like, "But
uh but isn't it weird that he mentioned her at all?" Call out
the liars. Call out the people who have to lie about what this
is. Call them out first once you've come on and said, "Okay,
you know what? Obviously Asmin Gold is lying. Techone is lying.
Destiny is lying. Dan is lying. These people are just lying to
Hassan because they're [__] losers, right?" Yeah.
After you say that, after you say that they're obviously lying,
obviously lying about Hassan, obviously just totally destroying
any faith people have in any sort of media ecosystem, right?
After you've engaged with that and admitted that, then we can
talk about Okay, now we'll pull it back to uh why should he have
mentioned her in like a rockus, you know, drama?
Yeah, probably to be honest. Hila participates. I think I think
it's funny that he throws out that Elila Klein participated in
raid to Ramala. I think it's funny. Wasn't Hila just on a podcast
like two days ago that was basically calling Hassan a Wasn't
she doing that? Like I I'm sorry. What do you want? I know exactly
what all of the replies to this are going to be, by the way.
They're all going to be But but people called CPS and they got
skulls sent to their house.
Why did he mention her at all? CPS skulls. Skulls. CPS CPS skulls.
Sword. God, it's just pathetic.
It's so [__] pathetic. All right, Dan, for ruining
the client's Dan is going to absolutely destroy Ethan Klein's
reputation. Dan has destroyed Ethan Klein's reputation. It is
sad. It was not linked to Oh, sure, sure, sure. Matt Slice. Yeah,
no worries, buddy. No worries. No worries. I'm I'm just glad
you're here with us, Matt Slice. We love you, buddy. We love
you. We're on Twitch today. I'm I'm going to do quite a bit of
this stream on Twitch. I think there's a good chance we get viewership
on Twitch today. Uh most of the chat is on kick, but if you guys
want to go participate on Twitch, it's twitch.tv/jsdk. TV/JLK
with an underscore. Okay, go buff the numbers over there. Listen
to my voice in both places if you can. Okay, if you're on your
computer, you can open up both. Open up both. Oh, it's JCLK with
an underscore, by the way. And don't forget to throw the primers.
Okay, primers, primers, primers. Any primers? Hello, Twitch gang.
Matt, Matt NLT's there with the Twitch gang. Okay, welcome. Welcome,
guys. I don't disagree with your take here. I just don't care
enough about Hassan to make a stand him. Yeah, here's the thing,
Alias Rain. Unfortunately, the same people who are maliciously
lying, writing total fanfiction about Hassan do the same to me.
So, I feel like, hey, I get to see firsthand how up this is,
right, all the time, over and over and over again. So, it matters
to me. It matters to me that people just lie. You're just willing
to lie about other people, right? I think you should be called
out. I think you should be embarrassed. Is this the uh is this
the O clip? Is the this clip from O
militants? Okay, it is perfect. >> Oh, hello.
What do we got? Matt NLT, thank you very much. That's a primer.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you. This feels odd. Welcome
to the Twitch chat, Alpha Kilo. Hold on. What's What is Ozel
linking? What is Ozel
Okay. No, Ozel. No. No, we're not pulling that up on stream.
Bro links a Discord link. Very strange.
Remember when Sam Hyde made Hassan a valid target and he hid
for days threatening to ban anyone in his chat that mentioned
it? Yeah, not even remotely the same thing obviously. Uh 80 IQ
engagement. Okay. No, no, no, no, no. Pens of goat. If Hassan
said, trust me, if Hassan said any violence against Ela Klein
is justified or something because she participated in the in
the IDF, we would have a totally different conversation right
now. But Hassan's a complete [__] We would be
down Hassan's throat today if he said some [__] like
that. Okay. We would be we would be destroying this [__]
guy. But he didn't say that, right? Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure.
Pens of goat. Sure. That it wouldn't be an explic explicit call
to violence. I don't think I need to make that delineation, though.
I'd be pretty annoyed either way. How long will it take for Hassan
to double down? Hassan already doubled down and said everything
he said there was correct, but he's also said a little bit more.
Local Glowy, thank you very much for the primer. For the primer.
That's a primer. We got a hype train going on Twitch now, guys.
Don't forget to get your primers in. All right, I'll pin I'll
pin the Twitch link for you in the kick chat as well. twitch.tv/j
TV/JCK
uh
hold on point. Yeah,
primers.
Let me pin that. There we go. Now,
I probably can just go to my own tweets here. I think I tweeted
the uh the other clip. Give me a second. Let me find the tweet
itself. But I I think I did both. Okay, I think I tweeted the
uh the other clip. Jesus, is this upstate trash guy mentally
ill? Sorry. Please return to whatever mental illness uh containment
zone you were in previously.
All right, hold on. What are we doing here? Oh, I'm looking for
I'm looking for my own clip. Hold on. It's somewhere in here.
It's somewhere in here.
>> It's in my replies with Dan. Okay, hold on. We'll watch
both of these.
Uh Macho, thank you very much for the gifted sub. Appreciate
you, dude. So, Dan gave me this clip right here, whatever this
is, to say Hassan, double down. Okay, take it up with Assan who
says it was not taken out of context. If he wanted to say that
you wish he what you wish he said, he should have said that.
He didn't. Well, we'll go through the Dan thread in just a little
bit. Okay, give me a second. Hassanabi confirming that the clip
is not out of context. Oh, it's a Destiny clip. Never mind. No.
Uh, somebody find me whatever time stamp Hassan's speaking at
there. We don't need to we don't need to put the [__]
vampire on screen. I'm good. Okay, hold on. So, this is going
to be quiet. I need to turn this up. But this is him saying exactly
what he means with regards to Gila Klein. >> They're saying
you currently think she's a valid target. No, of course not.
That's idiotic.
I've never I've never said that and I don't believe that. And
they're lying. It's the way it's clipped. No. No. That's >> okay.
No, that's there. There it is. He's just like, "No, obviously
I do obviously I do not think
obviously I do not think that Hila Klein's a valid target of
violence." Yeah, obviously. Right. Obviously, you might think
that, but he never said it. Hold on. Sensibility exchange his
Ela Klein in the He absolutely said and was clear that he's talking
about in the Gaza Strip and the West Bank. Do you think that
means it's a blanket call to violence like it's being presented?
Or do you disagree that he's talking about the Gaza Strip and
the West Bank explicitly and only those places? You have to disagree
with one of those things. So, which one do you disagree with?
Let's see.
He had his fingers crossed while he said that. Possibly.
Quite possibly. Unfortunately for us, okay, we're going to have
to endure some of the worst pain imaginable around this. All
right. No, the clip is weak.
What? Shut the up. The clip is not weak. It's obvious he's speaking
about the West Bank and the Gaza Strip while watching a documentary
about settler violence, armed settler violence in the West Bank.
It's the entire context of this. It is obvious in every sentence
he says. And you have to cut it off at the front, right? You
have to cut it off to make it not obvious.
Now, what happened to people who used to be I swear to God, a
bunch of these people are DJers. This is this is just another
thing. By the way, do you remember what who's this quote from?
Uh I don't stream in 20 second clips. So, if you got a if you
got like a 60-second clip of me, I don't stream in clips, okay?
I have a long conversation. So, I don't stream in clips. If you
got a clip of me, actually watch the full context.
Who's that? Who am I quoting right now? These people are literally
just using the the CEO's manifesto, all the stuff around that
as a guide for how to try to maliciously attack people, how to
lie about people on the internet, right? It's embarrassing. It's
sad. All right. Uh I was going to go I was thinking about going
to the Asmin Gold stuff next. Let's watch
>> talks about this a little bit after as >> By the
Palestinians doesn't matter if they're the Alaka Brigade. Doesn't
matter if they're a part of the Palestinian actual time from
this DFL, PFL. By the way, there's an obvious reason that all
of this didn't come out four or five days ago when it happened,
right?
It's that they know there if Hassan had actually openly called
for Hila Klein to have violence done to her, said, "Hey, you
guys, any violence against Ela Klein is justified." That would
have been front page news instantly, within seconds, right? The
the reveal on this is that the the stream is from 5 days ago.
That's how I knew immediately. I'm like, "Oh, somebody's making
some up here." And I immediately look for the context, right?
puppy or even former fat militants. Okay, it is perfectly legal,
perfectly valid, and perfectly moral.
Okay, 100%. This is not like a black and this is not a gray area.
This is black and white. Okay, it doesn't get more black and
white than this. Israel is in the wrong. Israel is actually engaging
in an >> You're going to hear these words so many times,
by the way, >> aparttheid, which is a crime in and of itself.
Israel is doing a genocide in Gaza and an aparite in the West
Bank. Two crimes in and of itself. And every >> Oh, I can
tell you exactly what they what they looked up. They went, "Oh,
there's a reference to Hila Klein here. How can we spin it? There's
a reference to Klein. How can we spin it?" That's all that's
all the thought that went into this. Okay? There's no actual
thought that goes in. every type of armed resistance against
both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force in the
West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcasters like
uh wife that participate in these raids. The violence that the
Palestinians
engage in in an act of resistance against this illegal occupying
force is literally legal. Definitionally legal. Okay? It's just
the truth straight up. It doesn't matter that they look to be
in garb that makes you think >> that they're in the right.
Okay. >> I think he called her Yeah, he said your favorite
podcaster's wife. He's obviously referring to Ela cuz he says
who participated in these raids >> and right now life is
tough for Palestinians in the West Bank. >> Oh, there's
just nothing else. >> They feel powerless. Random milit.
So again, all within the context of the West Bank, watching a
documentary on the West Bank. >> Operations, security checks,
and barriers restricting movement can happen anywhere and at
any time, making normal movement impossible. There's the continuous
threat of attacks by
>> West Bank of Bair. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Uh maybe who believe
the land is theirs. >> It's uh it's it's just so goofy.
It's all so so so goofy. Let's check out some of the comments
from LSF really quickly. Bro really had to make sure absolutely
sure we knew he was talking about Hila here. Lol.
Yeah. I mean, he's he's trying to drive home a point that he
knows that the Palestinians look scary. Even their militants,
their their uh their militias look scary. And the IDF looks like
kind of like white people in military uniforms. They look not
scary. But it doesn't matter. You're part of the occupying military
force in occupied illegally occupied lands. Okay, that's the
point. So he's saying if she was an active duty person participating
in reign, she would raid, she would be a valid target regardless
of status, right? Yes. That if she went on that raid, she would
be a valid target of violence.
Yes. Yep. That's what that's what he's saying. If she was an
active active duty and she went on that raid, if somebody her,
that would be a justified act. Now, we can fight on that point.
Okay. We can fight on that point. I don't know if I agree on
that. Okay, it would depend on if somebody like, you know, fired
an RPG at the car, maybe justified. Okay, if somebody, you know,
captured her and then her, I would say no, not justified.
It would depend on the situation, right? I, by the way, I don't
think Ela Klein's like a particularly bad person. I'm saying
that in the context of you're an IDF member, you're going on
a raid into the West Bank, right? I don't have sympathy for you
if violence is done to you. If you're an IDF member going on
a night raid into the West Bank, I do not have sympathy for you.
I'm sorry. I don't don't think Ela Klein's a bad person. Don't
think she needs to be attacked. Don't think I obviously denounce
anybody calling for violence against her in the in the current
day or violence against her family or even harassment towards
her family. Right. I actually do disavow the CPS stuff. As much
as I like joke about how big a deal has been made, I obviously
disavow that. That's obviously bad. I like that's horrible for
the kids, right? The skulls. I think the skulls is bad, too.
I think all of that stuff is actually bad. I totally disavow
that. Don't harass people. There's no reason to. That's the same
as what's being done to other people by Dan, by Destiny, right?
They're trying to make people feel intimidated in real life so
that they can keep lying, so that they don't get criticized for
lying. Obviously, I disavow it happening to people I don't like
or think are doing bad things. Everybody's in this internet environment.
Don't try to Don't try to menace them for their speech. Don't
be a [__] loser. Just win in terms of the speech.
just win in terms of the arguments. Okay, that's all it's got
to be. Based on what you've said so far, I know that you are
going to get Clipchimp, too. Okay, that's fine. We'll just keep
having these actual arguments. We'll just keep having them, right?
And I know I know that I'll win.
That's how it is. You didn't say morally this clip would actually
be worse unironically. At least now we can argue whether or not
morally it's right to drive out an occupi occupation force. Sure,
cuz I don't know if legally that's true. I I assume it's wrong,
by the way. I assume legally that Hassan has no legal understanding
of what goes on in the West Bank. I assume he doesn't know international
law. I assume he says it's illegal because that's like his propaganda,
right? That's what I assume. Hold on. Hold on. Okay.
Are we going to go to As are we ready to go to Asmin Gold already?
No, no, no, no, no. Let's do the the reaction here. Okay. Ela
went on Instagram and reacted to this. Okay. Got an ELA reaction
here. We'll watch the We'll look at the ELA reaction. Ela Klein
responds to Hassan calling her a valid military target. Just
another Sunday. Hassan [__] who exposed by my husband
to be a disgusting creep. He's not. Uh, let's see here. Hassan
[__] who's exposed by my husband to be a disgusting
creep, has retaliated by calling for violence against me. Think
back and you'll notice a trend that when he wants to get an uh
at Ethan, he attacks me. This is just another glimpse into the
psyche of a man who does not see women as equal. What? The comment
he made is totally valid in that situation. It's not like he
had to do any stretching. There's no stretching that happened
there, right? He's saying, "No matter how nice the IDF looks,
I don't give a [__] He look just going on her night
raid for for like one time. I don't care. You're an IDF member
entering as a part of a raid into Raala. [__] you."
That's what he's saying. There's no happening there. That's not
happening at all. What are those pants? I Those pants are goofy
as [__] Okay, he's got parachute pants on. That's
crazy. Oh, this is just a glimpse into the psyche of a man that
does not see women as equal, as his equal. He uses women to whatever
end he needs, be it revenge, gratification, or to massage his
ego by exposing their new bodies without their consent to his
boys.
Again, uh I just find it very weird personally how they're trying
to uh equivocate, okay, equate to two situations. Uh listen,
maybe we have to review that document. Maybe we have to go in
and actually expose how these people are just lying repeatedly
over and over and over again. She's referencing the Ethan/ Assassan
debate where he kept referring to Hila as your Ethan's wife.
Okay, who gets mad about that kind of thing? Who really gets
mad about that? Hey, how did I meet this person? Oh, I met them
as the wife of somebody else I cared about. Oh, well, that's
how I will know them. That's all it is in somebody's head, right?
Hassan calls a valid military target. Okay, just another Sunday.
Okay, these people are just fishing for money so transparently.
It's sad. Uh, it's sad. I totally talked to Hutch about this,
but um I think he thinks that uh I'm unhinged. Okay, he he just
believes lies. Unfortunately, Hutch just believes lies. I don't
think Hutch really understands or can internalize, but he just
believes lies and it's kind of sad. I've had enough with Zod
and his [__] Goon squad. Okay, no matter where you
stand on Israel Palestine, how could you target someone like
Klein Hila? Wait, is this reposting Ethan? Oh, Tom Ward. It's
Tom Ward. Okay. She's generous, kind, caring, and an amazing
wife, mother, and boss. And she hasn't harmed anyone, so go yourselves.
I mean, is okay. Maybe maybe she doesn't participate at all,
and maybe he shouldn't mention her, but I I feel like I've seen
her mention things enough that like this reference didn't seem
like evil to me, okay, personally.
But hey, whatever. If Ela Klein like gets up and says, "I'm going
to walk away. I don't want to participate in this." I I'll say
this much, okay? If Hila Klein anytime the Hassan thing comes
up because of the heat that's been brought, she goes, "You know what?
I don't want to be here. I'm going to remove myself." If she's
like taking active steps to remove herself, then I think she
shouldn't be mentioned. I think you should probably try to lay
off personally. That's my personal morality. Okay? I don't know
if I could tell other people to do the same, but if she actively
tries to remove herself, she says, "I don't want to be here when
you talk about Han." Then you know what? You should probably
leave her alone. But I don't know enough about the H3 podcast.
I don't watch. So, if she if she does that, I think Hassan's
wrong to name her. I don't I still don't believe that there's
any truth to the claim that he's calling for violence against
her, but he's wrong to name her in the first place. Okay. The
only person who doesn't want to participate is Olivia. Okay.
Yeah, it seems fine. All right. I got Hassan's reaction to this
apparently. Oh, maybe I should wait and use the YouTube video
for Hassan's reaction or something. Hassan Parker was exposed
by my husband to be a disgusting creepers retaliator by calling
for vans against me. Think back and you'll notice a trend. When
he wants to get at Ethan, he attacks me. This is just another
glimpse into the psyche of a man who does not see women as his
equal. >> Dude, I can't I can't listen to Hassan Reed without
just losing it. >> Dude, this is literally Okay, dude.
Girl bossing genocide defense
who was exposed by my husband to be a disgusting creep has retaliated
by calling for violence against me. Think back and you'll notice
a trend. What he wants to get at Ethan, he attacks me. This is
just another glimpse into the psyche of a man who does not view
women as equal. Okay, dude. Okay, dude. Okay, dude. Wait, did
he even respond? Why wouldn't they clip the response? Why is
there no response here? Why? What are we doing? This is literally
girl bossing genocide defense. >> Girl bossing genocide
defense. >> I'm sure there's more response here, right?
We'll we'll get into Hassan's response from today. I'm sure he's
going to go through a bunch of this stuff. I don't know. We could
do it from the Hassan angle or we could do it from like everybody
else as well. I kind of do want to go into it. All right. Okay.
We've got quick update. Okay. On Nicholas Dioro,
I I think Nick is better than a lot of other people on this.
Okay, I do. But I also have some issues with the way Nick handles
things.
I don't know if Maybe we just get into it now. Oh, let me do
this. Let me post this on my timeline. Guys, I hate to say it,
but you are not
you're not up to snuff right now. Okay, guys. Go and engage with
the blastoff tweet. It is pinned in both chats. Oh, it's not
pinned in the kick chat anymore. Okay, there's the blastoff tweet.
Engage with the blast off tweet. Like the blast off tweet. Leave
a comment. Leave a meme. All right. Engage with the blast off
tweet so that we get out to as many voices as possible. Okay,
let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Thank you. All right.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Where are we here? Oh, Nick.
Right. Nick. Nick. Nick. We're on Nick. Okay. Let's close some
tabs. We're going to have to keep tabs cleaned up here. We've
got Nick over here doing his thing. So, with the original clip
from Oh, the clip from Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold went off. Okay.
Asmin Gold was going the off
about this stuff. All right. I'm sorry. I don't have a Twitter.
Go register one right now. Dolce Bellum in Expertise. Go register
one right now cuz I need you to join. We're going to start a
Twitter community right away as well. Okay. Unfortunately, this
is just a game. Okay. I don't I don't particularly like Twitter.
I don't really like social media all that much, but it's the
game. Okay. You got to be on Twitter. You got to be doing [__]
on Twitter. Okay. It's the game. It's how it's played. So, I
need you to register a Twitter account and get yourself involved.
All right.
You need to do it. You need to do it now.
It's important. So, Nicholas just looks at this and says, "This
drama is escalating to a really scary place. I don't like this
engagement from Nick personally." Okay. Uh, you do this and you
say, "You're basically just lending credence to this narrative,
right?" And he hadn't looked into it yet. And if you don't remember,
he apparently did this with Willy's video as well. He had not
seen any of Willy Mack's video. He just retweeted it and then
he didn't go back. It's like you can't amplify stuff and go like
this is the correct thing. You can't imply it's correct and yeah,
this is how it is and then not clean stuff up. Okay.
Now, I think I think you should delete this tweet probably. That's
that's what I would say if you're going to go and and try to
clean stuff up. But Nick is Nick is miles ahead. Okay. He is
infinitely better than most of the people commenting on this
from that perspective. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I see. I see.
We're going to we're going to go through his three tweets. All
right. I will say he's better, but I I still don't like it. Okay.
I still don't like it because of the Willy Mac thing where he
retweets the Willie video and then instead of actually going
and saying, "You know what? That video doesn't represent my views."
He leaves his uh like his endorsement of it up
and then won't criticize the things that are wrong with it, the
blatant lies in it. Okay. Okay.
He tweets out, "Support for Ela Klein is pivotal right now."
Um, again, this is the probably the second or third time at minimum
that I've seen him go and just bite the bullet on some narrative
that isn't true, right?
He wants to have his cake and eat it, too.
He wants to eat and have a cake. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay, dude.
All right, dude. So, I think there's a So, Nick does post on
this. I think there's additional context to the recent Asan tweet
that's worth watching, but I'm going to keep this up, too. The
controversy really brought out the bloodthirsty people who want
someone to die over this drama.
Yeah. Wait, hold on. Can we go and call out the other people?
Did you see Ralph's reply to Dioro? No, I do know Ralph replied.
I I've seen some of the Ralph stuff. Okay, but I I haven't pulled
it out yet. So, I think this clip is reckless, but it's also
out of context. He's making a point about valid military targets
of IDF soldiers actively occupying the West Bank. He's invoking
Hila Klein in the past tense to reference the ride along, but
Palestinians or supporters attacking her in California would
not be an act of resistance. It would be offense. Yeah, obviously.
Obviously, it's a lie, right? But I think if you if you're going
to buy into the lie and you will not call out the liars, it doesn't
it's you're like not doing enough. There's not enough there.
If you buy into the lie, you need to call out the people who
who had you buy into the lie. Okay? You have to. That's like
a prerequisite. Close to the clip you linked with some leadup.
What is this? >> That is >> Okay. This Hassan today.
All right. All right. All right. Here. Let's uh let's give this
a listen. I also have taken a bunch of I drank a bunch of caffeine
here. So, give me a second. I'm going to use the bathroom while
we listen to Hassan. Okay. While he starts cooking on this, let's
watch this really quickly and then So,
sorry. To begin with, Nick does actually come out. So, he's infinitely
better than other people, but I do think you got to call out
the liars, man. You got to you got to call him out. Even if it's
up your networking, right? Like, dude, there are people just
lying about this. Like, like this uh this OP guy, he's just lying.
He's just going to lie. Bunch of people lying. Stop letting yourselves
get manipulated. Okay, you got to stop. Okay. Oh. Uh I think
Hassan is pretty careless here, but if your takeaway is that
Hassan supports vigilante justice or Palestinians harming Hila
Klein in California current day, that's clearly not the point
he was intending to make. All the more reason to clip him in
context and not overly embellish clips that can be defeated by
quickly scrolling back. Bad empanada existing is a good enough
argument. Doesn't help that he platforms bad and panata and Noah
uh Noah, two people who have both threatened Ela in the current
day. That like this is just true, right? That you should actually
cons you should actually criticize Hassan for the things he says.
But I'm I'm not that's not even enough yet. Okay, why don't you
call it yeet? I did just call it yeet. I said yeet was lying.
The 20,000 guy just completely lying with the clip. And I'm saying
that uh like actually Nicholas should be calling him out too.
How can you say it's reckless and stupid but say he's making
a point about valid military targets? It's contradictory state.
Wait, he does we would all think the IDF in Raala engaging in
like any occupying force whatsoever like going in and violently
doing almost anything in Ramla. Okay. Aside from defending like
another IDF member who got taken down and like beaten to death,
right?
But basically almost anything they're doing in Ramala would not
be okay. Very easy. Actually, I didn't I at no point that said
Hassan made a good or bad point. Yeah, exactly. People think
when I'm like specific about what Hassan's saying. I don't even
agree with his points. I don't I don't agree with his points.
I'm just saying that other people are lying and muddying the
waters and just trying to attack him. That's what's clear, right?
That's the sad thing. Okay, we'll watch this. That's the Nick
stuff. Nick's doing better than everybody else. So, I I feel
like I have a higher bar for Nick. I expect Nick to function
as a human being. Okay.
The rest of these people are scum. They're just scum. They're
losers. I don't expect them to meet the bar of humanity that
I would expect of Nick. Okay, Nick. I want him to be like a human
and call out the people lying. But honestly, I'll never say that
to him personally because I feel like when you tell him like,
"Hey, you should do this." It's uh it pushes him in the other
direction. It's kind of unfortunate, but it is. Nick set up the
higher bar for himself. That's true, Cosmo. That is true. Okay,
give me two seconds. I'm going to play this. I need to get some
water. Use believe that that is illegal. Okay, in the clip, but
everyone is just going along with it. There is no point where
I have said violence against someone who is not actively in combat
is permissible.
>> Okay, that is ridiculous. I don't believe that. That
is illegal. This is not, you know, and also immoral. It's a big
part of the reason why I also advocate against what Israel is
doing. I have also specified that IDF veterans are not valid
military targets. Okay? Just because someone is an IDF vet or
a veteran in general, if they're in a hospital bed or if they're
uh living out their days,
that doesn't make them a valid military target. This is an intentional
mischaracterization of my words, but >> it doesn't even
necessarily uh it doesn't even seem to be it doesn't even seem
to be out of context. >> Okay, I'm back. Uh, I really wish
he hadn't said, "I haven't advocated for violence against anybody
who's not active in actively in combat." I don't think Elo was
ever actively engaging in combat. I He's just He's like concerned,
right? But I'm not going to go and do the thing where I where
somebody gets lied about and they get a little too aggressive
on their defense and they say something that's not like totally
in line with their previous statements and I'm going to go and
like try to like nitpick on that now. Right. Jay hasn't disavowed
yet. What? Wait, what happened?
Uh, sorry. I'm back now. Uh, how can Nick even say Hassan is
even careless? Imagine talking about the in the context of USA,
let's say some Mexican military forces just do a raid on your
home and you can't fight back. Um, I think the recklessness is
the mention of Hila Klein in the context of valid military targets.
He's probably going to say that's reckless. I don't think that's
reckless. I think he was pretty obvious with what he's saying.
Okay. Oh, Max sent five subs. Hold on. Hold on.
No, Max didn't send five subs. Max said, "Hey, valid military
targets. Orders understood." Oh, Max, get the out of here. Okay.
No, no, no. We've disavowed. We disavowed that. I was away. Okay.
I wasn't at my desk, but thank you for That's crazy how you time
that, Max. I said I'm going to the bathroom. You immediately
sneaked that in. I see what you're doing. I see how you're trying
to get me. [__] you. Okay.
[__] you. Can't get me. Uh, yeah. So, he said like
actively in combat, right? Oh, I I've never called for violence
against somebody not actively in combat. Well, Elo is never actively
in combat, but I think he's just trying to say like an active
militant, like a member of the military in a combat zone or something
like that. And I am going to give charity there cuz again, when
people are just lying about you, I sort of understand how you
might overdefend. All right. In any case, he's never once called
for violence against Hila. Okay? Never, ever, ever, ever, ever.
And people saying so are lying to you.
And realistically, I'm starting to find the more interesting
conversation for me is why are these people lying? What is the
goal? Why are they lying in unison? Why are they all amplifying
the same lies? That's more where I'm going to. Okay, that's the
more interesting conversation to me. It's not even really about
what Hassan said anymore. It's, hey, why are these people just
like making up lies about other people? What's going on here?
What is going on here exactly?
They take out of context what you said that if everyone behaved
like the idea that nuking Tel Aviv is permissible. Yeah. If if
Israel's targeting standards were international law where you
could literally people and their family members as Israel has
been doing in Gaza, then yes, I don't believe this, but that
would be the case. I don't think it's appropriate and I don't
agree with it. I hate this out of context clip where Asana is
saying we should kill Israelis. Violence is everything is I think
we should kill Hassan as punishment. Yeah, pretty much. >> There
are people saying that you should call for violence against Assad
right now. That is a thing that's happening, right? It's it's
crazy based on the previous clip where we can all agree that
Hassan is not painting Hila as a valid target of any violence.
Based on that clip, there are people who are calling for violence
against Hassan now based on the lie.
Now, for me personally, I would say if you're propagating these
lies, I think you know what you're doing. I think you are I think
I know what we can all see what you're doing. Okay? You're raising
the temperature. You're you're getting people to call for violence
against Assad. All it's all muddying the waters. is all trying
to make this guy look as bad as possible and trying to make other
people who say similarly unhinged, okay, to the lies they're
saying. They're basically trying to paint everybody else as like
totally unhinged. Oh, everybody's everybody on the internet is
all unhinged. Everybody's the same. It's all just a big muddy
thing of unhinged crazy people who dox each other and call for
the death of each other. Nope. No, it's not. It's not. That's
not what's happening. You're lying. Stop lying. Stop trying to
make it so everybody's like you. That's just you. You're the
weird freaks. Everybody else is looking at you and seeing you
as a weird freak. Okay, stop trying to pretend that any of us
want to do this. We don't. Nobody else wants to do this. [__]
you. The meta is now clips go viral on here and then get shared
on Twitter. You even said in your original debate with him that
she's not a legal target. These people are just making controversies
for the fun of it. Yeah. Do you Oh god, the Ethan Ralph tweet.
It goes way harder than I thought.
Support for Ethan Klein is pivotal right now. Sorry, Ethan Klein.
Helilocline. Support for Helilocline is pivotal right now. And
Ralph comes in and says, "Nah, I'm good on that. Nah, nah, I'm
good on that. No thank you. No thank you. Nah, I'm good on that."
Also, this whole thing is twisted. His mom was talking about
offering her back when she was in the military, which would have
been perfectly moral and legal under international law since
the IDF is an illegal occupying force. I don't know if that's
true. Uh, oh, and here's her record, and he just re he just adds
a gatumodor tweet.
Uh, Ela Klein served as the aid to camp to the commander of the
IDF brigade, specifically tasked with conducting security operations,
night raids in and around the city of Ramla. She planned and
participated in the illegal force disappearance disappearances
of people from their homes. Now, I don't know how accurate that
is. She was a part of some force that did night raids into Raala.
She went on one, right? I don't know what her actual role was.
I know she was a secretary, man. I don't know how complicit she
was. I'm not totally sure. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know
how true any of that is. It's a Gat Fumodor tweet, so I assume
there's a lot of lies in here. Okay. Just like when I see, you
know, people saying that Hassan called for Ela Klein to get killed.
When I see a Gat Fumador tweet, that's a huge flag. I'm like,
"Oh, I think a lot of that's probably not true." Actually, Gat
is one of the most bad faith. Yeah. See, this is just people
going after Gat. Do people not understand mandatory military
service? I don't know. If they can mandatorily force you to go
do night raids into Ramallah, then that's a issue Israel needs
to solve. Okay, that's that's that is uh like I don't even that's
like threatening people to break international law based on based
on a threat that you'll jail them. I think that's entirely on
Israel.
Ela did volunteer to go on this raid as well.
But here's the thing. I don't believe like did crazy in that
raid. Ghetto is one of the most consistently bad faith people
in this whole thing. Lies constantly didn't participate participate
in the raid. She was asked to a singular ride along on a raid
she didn't know the background of. She never planned anything
either. Oh, you don't know any of that. I don't think she's spoken
on any of that. I don't know what she did as a part of this,
right? But I would say that I just don't believe it when I see
Gatumodor say it. She did go on a night raid. Uh it seems like
the Palestinians knew what those night raids meant because I
believe she's talked about how their car was getting hit with
bullets as they drove into Raala. Right. Her talking about it
is in suggestions. Okay. Okay. Let's check it out. This her talking
about it. Well, I thought I thought I'd seen her talk about it.
So one time I wanted to go with them just to experience it. >> Why
were all of a sudden had a urge? >> I wanted to go just
to experience it. So I already feel like we're too far forward
here. >> There's like a I don't know the terms in English
from the army,
>> So there was a I was in DIAT which is like a like a
brigade I guess that's in charge of the area of Ramla >> and
that brigade has like a main >> So I was his secretary.
>> Okay. So you were >> Oh, so aid the aid the camp
is I mean people don't like the terms but she is the secretary
to the commander of the brigade. That's true. >> Right
below the big boy. >> So it was nice. It was interesting.
It was more demanding in a way but also kind of more rewarding
cuz you're put in this weird situation where you're like you
don't you're away from your house. >> You have this new
group of people that you have to get along with >> and
I it's hard to explain but for some reason it was more interesting.
I enjoyed it more. You told me once you went on like a mission
with them >> to like a terrorist city. >> that was
kind of a crazy >> to like a terrorist city. The city of
Ramala story. >> Yeah. The So my officers and like the
the soldiers in that brigade um they would go every night on
a raid >> in Romada to to arrest terrorists.
>> uh man, I'm sorry, but like dude, I'm sorry. If you
think that the IDF engages in some up practices, then a brigade
that does nightly raids into Raala, I'm sorry. You do nightly
raids into Ramala,
I'm sorry, man. Those are probably some pretty cooked individuals,
right? I think we can all agree. I don't know if she's like a
psychopath, but people who are going into Raala every night,
dude, come on, man. >> Um, so I always saw them preparing
for it and leaving and then I would stay in the base. >> So,
one time I wanted to go with them just to experience it. >> Wow.
You just were all of a sudden had an urge to go with him. >> I
just wanted to see what it's like. I wanted to see it. >> So,
um it Yeah, they took him. They took me with him one night even
though they weren't supposed to. >> Did they armor your
up? >> Um you're driving in this like jeep that's bulletproof,
right? >> So, I was in the jeep and then um as soon as
we entered Ramada, the people in the city started Wow. >> And
I heard like a bullet hit the jeep like right next to my head.
>> Did you Did it like dent or just hear your gnarly armored
jeep?
And
I mean it was >> like, okay, it's just I still don't think
she'd necessarily I think she's probably somebody and I I'm going
to grant a lot of charity here. Okay. I think she's probably
somebody who didn't really know exactly what was going on. Okay.
And I think if she'd been like captured, I don't think she'd
be a valid target for violence. I think the vehicle possibly
would have been a valid target for violence if it was driving
in there every night, right? I think that's probably true. She's
probably embellishing.
I don't know if she's embellishing. I I would believe they take
the IDF vehicles with like AKs and I totally believe that. But
I don't know. I don't know if she knew exactly what was going
on, man. I again, no proof she prove she planned anything. I'm
probably holding back from saying she's a valid target, but Oh,
embellishing.
Sure. Sure. >> They were shooting. So, someone actually
was shooting car when you went in there right away. >> Huh.
Did you have a gun on you? >> I didn't. >> You were
not supposed to leave? >> No. Yeah, not really. But even
if I I mean I I walked with them to one house. I did get out
of the car once but but surrounded with them. So >> Okay.
Did they arrest anyone that night? >> They did. >> Did
they bring it in the same car with you? No. >> Oh god.
There's a few cars going. >> Yeah. That's crazy. Was it
like how did you feel? Was it horrifying? >> It was strange.
Very very weird. >> How? Like how? >> I don't know.
Just you see people in the house and then it's like the soldiers
go just walk into the house and look through their and find guns
and the whole thing is really surreal. >> Okay.
I'm sorry. Like that sounds like she participated some she was
a tertiary participant in some pretty up. Okay,
that's that seems to just be like a fact in this case.
Do I think it sounds like she went on one raid and she probably
could have easily gone on another one. It sounds like some happened
where she was like, "You know what? Uh, no thanks. You know what?
One was enough for me and she's probably not going to talk about
the she saw. But like, you know what?
One's One's enough for me. Okay, no more. Sure sounds sure sounds
like she was doing work for the active combatants she joined
into a raid with. She was she would have been aiding them. I
think there's there's like an argument there that I disagree
with. Right. It's like I would disagree with it. I would just
disagree with it. But I don't think I don't think that's the
same. I don't think that's even close to just calling for violence
against Ela Klein. Okay. I don't think reviewing this and looking
through it is calling for violence against Eva Klein, too. Uh,
unequivocally we denounce any calls for violence, any any violence
that's done in the name of like internet coverage of
different personalities, right? You'd be [__] insane
to think that anyone wants that. For one raid, she was a valid
target. I I think it depends. I said this black ice. It depends
on if she was like captured or if like like I think the vehicle
was a valid target. I think her squadmates seem to have been
valid targets. I don't know if I'd think she was a valid target
and and like if she got hurt in the course of them going after
the her squadmates or the car, I don't think that would be a
problem, right? I don't think I would have like a lot of I guess
uh what would you call it? Like criticism for that. But if she
was captured or something, I would think, okay, that's like a
secretary. You don't hurt that person. You like give them back
to is you ransom them back to Israel or something, right? Ransom
as in like, hey, give us some like food and money or something.
like you you but you you don't hurt people who aren't engaging
in violence. And I'd say she's probably not within she's probably
not in a mind state where she can even identify that violence
correctly. I wouldn't say she's like blameless, but she's not
like consciously to blame. Like she she's not consciously doing
something evil in my opinion. Are you She was doing a ride along.
Hey, it sounds like she saw some was pretty horrified by it and
like was like no no more no thanks. Again, it is mandatory military
conscription. Uh, it's possible, Tenstone. It's possible. I'm
just saying, man, I don't know. It's
Anyway, I think there's definitely an argument there, right,
over if you just take Ela Klein's name out of it. You just put
in like a secretary, like the secretary of the commander of this
unit that raised your every night and she pops out in like a
IDF uniform and armor or something, right? Is that a is there
like a moral wrong in targeting those people? I don't know. I
don't I don't know.
Right. If you just remove Ela Klein from it, I get a little less
hesitant to say, "Yeah, I mean, if she got, it's probably whatever,
right?"
But obviously living in Bair with her kids, she's out of that
entirely. She's not participating. She's I don't know that she
ever did any actual violence to people. I don't know if she ever
condoned it. And honestly, she grew up in Israel and she grew
up in Israel doing that mandatory service. She might not have
even been able to tell that this was bad. She might have just
totally believed that these people were terrorists. They're going
to hurt them, right? Like there's a certain amount of brainwashing
that goes on if you live in Israel.
Does it excuse like the more heinous acts? No. But does it excuse
somebody being able to like justify their secretary job? Possibly.
Yeah. When we make it big, we should kick it in West Hollywood.
Okay. Max,
hold on. Can I Hold on. Where is this? Is this it? No.
I was just going to go Max Max POV is hanging out in West Hollywood.
Okay. And it's going to be that guy that H3 reported on the guy
from Bair. That dude with the the pig mask or whatever. That's
Max hanging out in West Hollywood. Okay. But I can't find a clip.
So unlucky. The same people who cried about CPS. Uh 5 minutes.
Um I think that's different than CPS to be honest. This is just
wasting FBI resources, right? Like being a wasting FBI resources.
But it's different than the CPS thing. That's not getting like
uh miners involved in in some investigatory process. This is,
but it's like a different kind of They're both, right? And I'd
say this is slightly less.
Shouldn't waste the FBI's time with nonsense, but you know, it
is what it is.
Okay. Are we going to
Wait, did I miss a Matt Slice message? I did earlier. Sorry,
Matt Slice. Sorry, buddy. Twitch chat, bro. Okay, we need to
move on to the Asmin Gold stuff. Okay, we're going to cover some
Asmin Gold memes real quick. Let's check them out. I think we're
on to the Asmin Gold stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, we are. Okay. We're
going to watch actually quite a bit of Asam Gold's coverage of
this. All right. All right. It's that simple. RP is I want to
watch from the beginning cuz I don't want to lie about what he
says. I don't want to lie if he goes and finds context and he
still has the same opinions. All right.
I want to see it all. Let me see it all. >> Pretty big,
man. You're right. It's huge, but it's not as big as the game
itself. And that's my point. Hassan calls for the murder of Hila
Klene. >> Yeah. Okay. That seems insane to just to just
frame the clip that way. Seems pretty insane. Pretty motivated.
Kind of unfortunate, >> huh? That sounds pretty bad. Let's
watch >> Uh maybe we'll do the Roblox stuff. >> Uh
matter if they're DFLP, PFLP, or even former fought out militants.
Okay. >> Okay. Before we start this, guys, I really appreciate
the the Twitch viewers today, but I'm going to I'm going to go
over to kick only. Okay, that's how we make the money is kick
only. All right, I'm going to head over there. We're going to
be back on Kick. Okay, guys, head over to kick kick.com/jc. I
can't put the message in the chat for you or I would. All right,
kick.com/jok.
If you are watching on Twitch, head over to kick. All right,
we're going to shut that down. We're going to go Twitch. Sorry,
kick only for the rest of the stream. Have a good night, guys,
before we get really into the Asmin Gold stuff.
turn off multiream. All right, let's continue. Let's continue.
Let's continue.
Asmin Gold. Uh, okay. >> Matter if they're DFLP, PFLP,
or even former FATA militants. Okay. It is perfectly legal, perfectly
valid, and >> I don't think you should be saying it's perfectly
Wait, wait, let me finish. >> Oral. Okay. 100%. >> He
should not be saying that it's perfectly legal to do something
that's not legal. It's >> Ashold just like reads the title.
He's like, "This is exactly what happened." Who Who can stream
for this long and do that where you're like, "Oh, the title,
that's what happened." How do you not know that every person
who links you stuff is potentially? Not not a known, but like
you can have good linkers, right? But everybody who links you
is potentially. How do you just read the title and go, "Well,
this is what happened. He calls for Eva Klein." Wait, why is
he saying murdering Ela Klein is legal? Why would he say it's
legal? That's weird. >> Not legal to do anything to a person
because they were part of the IDF.
It's just not true. Like, he hasn't listened to the argument
yet. Obviously, he watched this off stream and he's like >> You
can say it's moral. That's fine. But like I mean I could disagree
with that. But you should not be telling people it's legal to
do this. That's crazy. >> This is not like a black if they're
DLP, PFLP, or even former fat militants. Okay. It is perfectly
legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral.
>> Okay.
100%. This is not like a black and this is not a gray area. This
is black and white. Okay. It doesn't get more black and white
than this. >> Israel is in the wrong. Israel is actually
engaging in an apartheid, which is a crime in and of itself.
Israel is doing a genocide in Gaza and an apartheid in the West
Bank. >> Two crimes in and of itself, >> And every
every type of armed resistance against both the settlers and
also the Israeli occupying force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter
if it's your favorite podcasters like uh wife that participate
in these ratings. Doesn't matter if >> Wow, man.
>> Wow. Oh boy. >> That's crazy.
>> That's crazy, chat. >> I mean, is he >> the
clip ends there? The clip does end there. Yes. he calling to
I mean like
>> he is is he calling that it's morally justified and
and it it's legal to have an armed resistance against like Ethan's
wife Hila.
>> No,
not outside of a very specific
>> That's crazy.
>> That's crazy chat. >> He's using coded language
to avoid directly saying it.
>> That's crazy. No, he's not. >> That's crazy, chat.
>> Where's the code?
There's no code. >> There really isn't a code. There is
no code. It is just obvious what's >> What do you mean?
Where's the coded language? Every type of armed resistance against
both the settlers and also the >> Yes, Alibaba. That is
what he's saying. That is the least violent, probably most morally
non-culpable person who could have participated in a raid into
the West Bank and they would still be a valid target is his opinion.
Israeli
is bad. Assan is bad. Hassan is bad. Assan is bad. Hassan is
bad. Okay, we're gonna cool down. Hassan is bad for a little
bit. Okay, we're going to cool it >> Every type of armed
resistance against both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying
force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite
podcasters like uh wife that participate in these. Doesn't matter
if they're DFL.
Oh, hold on.
>> Rob J. Hammond, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, dude. Guys, we are
>> What are we? We're >> looking like six subs away.
>> No, no, no, no. Hold on. Bad math. Bad math. Bad math.
Just chill. We're four subs away. Four subs away from another
hour on the stream. Let's go. Thank you very much, Rob. >> Um,
wow. Armed resistance equals death. I mean, how else would you
resist against a person? Yeah. I mean, calling for the death
of somebody, right? Yeah. I I I don't understand. Like, that's
cra that's really bad. That is That's super bad. Did he just
immediately go to Dan's Twitter? I feel like is it not just obvious
to me Dan is like totally destroying any reputation he could
possibly have, right? Like now, if if anybody comes back and
wants to actually be truthful about this, by the by the way,
this is why debate is bad, right? Cuz everybody who wants to
debate that Hassan is clearly calling for Ha Klein to be those
people would all get totally run over in any conversation. Dan
doesn't care. He does care. He just thinks he doesn't care, right?
Cuz it's not happening to him broadly because he's got a huge
community behind him who shout down anybody who criticizes him.
But eventually eventually
it there's just a market for this, right? You know how the argument
for co there not being like a conspiracy to spread CO or there
not being a conspiracy to like do vaccines and stuff. there's
like a a market for information. Okay. So, the reason we don't
think co vaccines are a conspiracy is because like Russia or
China would be incentivized to expose that, right? In this case,
people are going to be increasingly incentivized to expose the
way Dan lies maliciously, the way like that community lies maliciously,
the way they just write total fanfiction on people, right? It's
just going to be more and more and more obvious over time. And
there's going to be a bigger market incentive for somebody to
come along who's big and can not get shouted down to go, "Oh,
you guys are just like blatantly making up about people. We're
just sitting here like farming until that happens, right? It
will happen. It's obviously going to happen." No, Rich Jelly,
you're wrong. You're completely wrong. You're welcome to hop
in the Discord if you don't if you don't understand it or disagree.
The one that was bad was the uh Tom Cotton tweet. Okay, that
was way worse. That was way more ambiguous. That was way worse
than any of this. Holy [__] And this is the Oh. Oh,
okay. Here we go. The This is the better version. >> And
every
every type of armed resistance
against both the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force
in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcasters
like uh wife that participate in these raids. the violence that
the Palestinians
engage in in an West Bank. >> Hold on. >> Every time
full screen cuz he's just watching it. >> Oh,
both. >> There's a 30-cond version. There's a 30-second
version.
Here's the high quality edit of Hassan wishing for Hila's death.
By the way, As Gold really went, "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This isn't This isn't edited enough for me. Okay, this is giving
me too much context. I need somebody to strip away more context
so I can more clearly denounce this on." Oh, there's a 30-cond
version. Let's go. Let's go. >> And also the Israeli occupying
force in the West Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite
podcasters like uh wife that participate in these raids. The
violence that the Palestinians
engage in in an act of resistance against this illegal occupying
force is literally legal, definitionally legal. Okay? It's just
the truth. And no, it's not. If somebody attacks Hila Klene,
they're going to go to jail.
Why is he telling people this? Why would he be say What is wrong
with you? Yeah, everybody knows that.
Including Hassan. Hassan is not actually or not act advocating
for heal Klein to be right now. Yeah, she's he's not saying it's
legal. It turns out that Hassan didn't go live 5 days ago and
say actually murder is legal in the state of California. Shocker.
I know. I know. It's crazy. that Hassan, a guy with 20,000 viewers,
isn't enough to say, "Guys, if you murder this person, it's legal,
actually."
Yeah, he didn't do that. That's crazy.
If that actually happened, why wouldn't you have heard about
it when it happened? Dude, it's it's wild that people just civilians
and militants in the West Bank. It's not even civilians. It's
it's armed settlers because he's watching a documentary about
armed settlers. He's talking about settlers, right, in illegal
settlers in the West Bank and the IDF
right in the West Bank. Uh that where they're illegally occupying
the West Bank. That seems to be the case. Okay. It seems to be
what he's calling for. Do you think we'll get banned for this
at this point? I don't think so. I think that Twitch just doesn't
care. I I do. I think that Twitch is they're so ideologically
captured by like I I don't know what to do. Uh, I don't. He wants
in on >> So, I just want to point out that whoever told
Asmin Gold that this is the case, whoever told him to go check
out the Dan tweets, Asmin Gold, if you ever see this, you won't,
but if you ever to see this, this person is using you and destroying
your reputation, making you look like a complete to anybody who
cares to go and inform themselves. I hope I hope you understand
that that whoever is getting you to do this, right? If anybody
is pushing you towards these narratives right now, that person
is clearly trying to with your reputation. They're clearly trying
to sue you. All right.
In a lawsuit, >> as a reputation, he does a little bit.
He usually has a reputation for trying to be honest, right? That's
that's He thinks he's the guy who's just trying to give his honest
take, right? That's what he thinks. That's who I'm talking to
is Asmin Gold directly. You think you're the honest guy. You
think you're the guy who just looks at the facts, right? Why
wouldn't you gone and looked at a longer cut of this? What's
going on here? Uh, agree. Hassan did later clarify. No, he clarified
it in the moment. OMG's pro. You're too understand again. You
always come in here and you're like too moronic to understand.
Go watch the full clip. He's only talking about in the West Bank.
There is 0%, okay? 0% chance that anybody who's not malicious,
okay, that anybody who's remotely intelligent and not malicious
could look at this clip and say, "Oh, he's advocating for Hila
Klein to be attacked in California." You would have to be You'd
have to be so stupid. And I don't think most of you are that
stupid. Okay, most of the people who argue this, they're not
that stupid. They're just going to propagate whatever lie they
can about Hassan because they hate him. That's you, OMFG's pro.
You hate Hassan so much, you will do anything. You don't care.
You'll just lie as much as you want. Yes. So, I mean, like, he's
making a direct call for violence.
A a direct and immediate call for violence against people that
are American citizens.
Yeah. This is this is so unfathomably
my god. This is the this is the best commentator in America right
now. Okay. This is the biggest commentator for politics is a
guy who can't even be bothered to go find any context on this
and just says the most imaginable.
My god, dude. That's insane. Oh my god. Yeah. Now you come to
that clusion conclusion. Well, I mean, no, I' I've said that
before. I mean, I have. And so, yeah. uh make a post uh like
with Alpha Mike. Let's share it. Yeah, I think that's something
Ethan should report to the FBI. >> This isn't This isn't
even reckless. This isn't even close to reckless. It only looks
reckless when you strip the context away from it. That's the
only time it can look reckless is if you maliciously cut the
context away to make people think he's saying something he's
not saying. You have to lie to make it even reckless. It's still
not a direct call, but to even make it reckless, you have to
lie. Honestly, yeah. Like I I I'm gonna be real. Like I I I think
that like I mean at this point like you have like it's domestic
ter. Yeah. I mean report what report that you have a person that's
on a platform that's making an open call for violence and insinuating
that one specific person should be a victim to that. Do you really
think so? Let me go ahead and let let's let's actually evaluate
what he said and think if it's a threat or not. If he >> This
is a pointless exercise without watching the like additional
context.
>> Said that about Donald Trump. >> Completely pointless
exercise. >> Would the Secret Service be at his >> You
can't say this about Donald Trump. Donald Trump didn't serve
in the IDF. >> Yes,
that's right. Everybody knows this. So, the reason why is because
it's a >> Rick Jelly, you just are you're stripping again.
You're just stripping. You could you could say, "Oh, well, really
people might say Republicans should kill Rick Scott if they really
truly believe this." Anybody is sorry anybody that could take
that statement and go Hassan wants me to kill Rick Scott is so
stupid that it doesn't matter who they listen to they'll eventually
go do violence on somebody's behalf anyway
that person is just dumb I assume Rick that you are not that
dumb that you are capable of understanding what Hassan is saying
there right that is conditional if Republicans sincerely believed
that government fraud was bad they would Rick Scott is a statement
that is conditional on Republic on something that doesn't exist
Republicans don't give a [__] about American fraud
or government spending fraud because if they did, they would
do something about Rick Scott. Now, he goes aggressive there,
but he clearly is not. He's the whole point is he's criticizing
Republicans for not caring about fraud in government spending.
He's speaking to Mike Johnson specifically. I forgot that part,
but yes, it's like entirely conditional. Yes. Well, I mean, Rick
Scott was already a prominent member of the GOP. Everybody knows
it's a threat. It's not implied. It's not insinuated. It's stated.
He says it. Yeah. in 30 minutes. Yeah, exactly. Assan used her
as an example. I know that. Yes, that's exactly it. He has said
it about Trump. No, he hasn't said that. And he definitely has
said if you're in the West Bank,
>> Snick, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go. It's
another hour on the stream. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> 3 hours 3312
based. Thank you very much. >> Palestinian territory. No.
Well, no. No, because he said former FLP or even former FA militants.
Okay, it is perfectly legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral.
Okay, 100%. This is not like a black and this is not a gray area.
This is black and white. Okay, it doesn't get more black and
white than this. And he's also a he said former number one. He
did. >> Yeah. So, we called this out in the actual clip.
I didn't watch Asmin Gold do this, but I got told after the fact
that he did. I said anybody who takes that former piece, okay,
former Fatam members and they think that that's Hassan clearing
Israelis
for violence, you are too stupid to comment on anything to do
with Israel Palestine, please, please, please uninstall whatever
app you made your comment on and leave the internet. Walk away
in shame. Okay? Now, I'm not shaming anybody who just doesn't
know what feta is. Okay? You cannot know what feta is. But if
you are going to go and criticize Hassan's point here, right?
not understanding that you should leave. You should go away.
>> Um, number two, >> Asmin Gold does not understand
that when he says former Fatah members, he is saying even if
it was former Fatah terrorists, even if it's somebody who who
took over a airplane, all right? Even if it was that, I still
wouldn't care if they were doing violence on Israeli settlers
or the IDF in the West Bank or Gaza Strip. That would still be
Not only did he say former, but he stated her by name and she
was formerly in the military. There there's no there's there's
no talking around this, right? I mean, this is this is crazy.
Yeah. I mean, so Asmin Gold just doesn't understand. Asmin Gold
is a complete [__] Asmin Gold totally dropped the
ball here. I wish I could say something that was unique commentary
about Asmin Gold, but everybody's been saying this basically
every time this opens his mouth for 6 9 12 15 18 months now.
This guy just keeps putting his foot in his [__]
mouth. Hey, 30 seconds of work and look into this. It's not hard.
>> There you go. When he said someone has to do it, talking
about assassinating the president. Well, I I don't know when
he said that. I'd have to go back and see, but um yeah, there
you go. Podcaster's wife. Yeah. Uh tag Ethan. Oh, Ethan probably
already knows about this. It's not like it's a big secret or
anything like that, but um yeah. Uh let me go back. I'll see
if there's any more posts about this. And state of Palestine
is not recognized by United States. So, wouldn't Palestinians
legally be expected to follow Israeli law? >> Would be
nice if political influencers in general would be just a little
less bloodthirsty. Sure, call out the ones who are bloodthirsty,
right? Go call those people out. Make make some noise calling
those people out for being the pieces of [__] that
they are, right? Go after those people, but don't let those people
muddy the waters and say everybody's like this now or it's just
the environment. If you think this is just the environment, you
are brainwashed right now. Almost nobody is doing this, right?
Nobody is doing this. Son has justified violence against Israelis
outside of the West Bank. I swear to God, if you say something
like with regards to that embassy, you're you have to go Kogan
style. So, please be careful with whatever you say next where
he was justifying violence against Israelis broadly outside of
the West Bank. Please just be very careful. Please, please. >> I
have no idea. I mean, it doesn't really matter. But, um anyway,
uh this man could human being on stream and get away with it.
Yeah. And so
what I think is crazy about this is that like th this has been
a problem. I think that he justified October 7th. No, he said
October 7th was obviously going to happen, which is a useless
statement, but he didn't justify. He didn't say it was okay to
go those those people, right? He didn't say it was okay to go
those civilians. I believe he said it was okay to attack Israeli
military installations. And I have a hard time disagreeing with
that point. Okay. This has been this problem has been escalating
over time. And I think that especially ever since October 7th,
I think that Hassan has basically gotten more said it didn't
happen in a vacuum. Yes, that is saying it was obviously going
to happen. Everybody with two brain cells to rub together to
create a spark knows that it was inevitable. Knows that you can't
put people in those situations. You can't keep people pinned
up or penned up like that and not have that [__]
happen. Of course, there was going to be a terrorist attack.
Of course, I denounce it, but of course it was going to happen.
Both of those things, those aren't mutually exclusive at all.
Those are, you can believe both of those things very easily >> and
more and more extreme. And is he facilitating terrorism in this
chat? Is he promoting terrorism? Well, it's undeniable that he
promotes terrorism.
This is a this is an un Oh, we've reached step like eight in
the playbook now. Do you think Assan doesn't believe it was justified?
I can only go off of the statements he's made. I believe he thinks
the attacks on Israeli military installations were justified.
I believe he thinks the attacks on civilians broadly were not
justified. And if you have statements that contradict that, go
ahead and send them to me. Okay.
Undeniable objective fact. >> No. Rick Jelly, you're engaging
in like this office where people like ask these stupid questions
instead of actually asking intelligent questions. Well, what
do you believe he thinks? What do you think he thinks? Uh, just
I I believe based on the statements I've seen, I gave you my
position already, right? what he thinks and beyond that you're
like, "Well, don't you think in his heart of hearts he really
thinks it's all justified? You're asking me to just mind readad
negative intent into him. I have no interest. It's such a useless
exercise." Yeah. So, so step nine is OMFG. He's pro coming in
and saying Hassan supports Second Thought and Second Thoughts
that it's based. Okay. Okay. I don't I don't know what to tell
you. Yeah. He has he has friends who are idiots. Many of us are
cursed with this. >> He It's dis >> Now I just clicked
forward. I'm I'm so annoyed now. It's that simple. >> Wasn't
paying attention with my trackpad
let's share it. Yeah, I think that's something Ethan should report
to the
>> Honestly, yeah,
>> I don't want to go to the >> against people that
are American
>> He's not. >> That's not calling for violence against
American citizens. >> Oh my god. Yeah. Now you come to
that clusion conclusion. Well, I mean, no, I' I've said that
before. I mean, I have and so yeah, uh make a post uh like you
know who did Tom Cotton. Oh, well, Hassan totally did it back
and it's totally that Hassan did it back. Hassan did basically
say you should kill Tom Cotton. That is what Hassan did and he
did it in a coded way. By the way, when Hassan is saying you
should kill somebody, he's too much of a to say that directly.
We've seen how he does it with Tom Cotton. Okay, he did say go
kill Tom Cotton. That is what he said. Now, you could argue Tom
Cotton was saying pretty easily that Tom Cotton was saying just
run over these protesters, right? But he did he did call for
that guy's death and that's how he does it. He doesn't do it
out in the open. He's too much of a >> with Alpha Mike.
Let's share it. Yeah. I think that's something Ethan should report
to the FBI.
Honestly, yeah, >> that's the I'm going to be real. Like
I I I think that like >> honestly, yeah, you should totally
report this guy to the FBI. I haven't looked into it yet, but
you should totally report this guy to the FBI now. This is malicious.
Now, honestly, hold on. Let's see. >> Reuben donated $3.
Why does Mongold's brain keep trying to say occlusion? Freudian
slip much.
>> Sure. Thank you, Reuben. Ruben. Okay, hold on though.
Now, here's the thing with Asmin Gold. And I I'm asking cuz I
don't know. At what point does this become defamation per se?
That you are just you're refusing to look into this at all. You're
saying he said something he didn't say that he clearly didn't
say if you look into it, right? Could Assad not say that this
is defamation per se? You're accusing him of a crime that he
is actually calling for violence against Ela Klein when he is
clearly not
like actively currently calling for violence right now approximately
against Ela Klein. To me that seems like isn't threatened defamation
against people like a total [__] Well, hold on. I
would say you should just say Aspen Gold, you should actually
take this back like I didn't I didn't go to commit a crime here
and you're accusing me of committing a crime. I'm telling your
audience to report me to the FBI.
That's crazy. It would have to be a complete statement of fact.
Well, what does he want Hassan to be reported to the FBI for?
Like, I mean, at this >> He said he's advocating for violence
against American citizens. I don't think that's what it is. I
don't think that's what's happening here. No, not for defamation
per se. If you're accusing somebody of a crime,
uh, who said this is neoc, I believe if you're accusing somebody
of a crime, if you're saying you have committed a crime, this
crime, I believe that is defamation per se, you can't do that
without knowing they've committed it. If you It doesn't have
the same bar as just defamation of a public figure. point like
you have like it's domestic ter. Yeah. I mean report what? Report
that you have a person that's on a platform that's making an
open call for violence and insinuating that one specific person
should be a victim to that. Do you really think so? Let me go
ahead and let let's let's actually evaluate what he said and
think if it's a threat or not. If he said that about Donald Trump,
would the Secret Service be at his house? Yes.
That's right. Everybody knows this. So, the reason why is because
it's a threat. Everybody knows it's a threat. It's not implied.
It's not insinuated. It's stated. He says it. Yeah. In 30 minutes.
Yeah. Exactly. Assan used her as an example. I know that. Yes.
That's exactly, >> dude. It's like just lying. It's just
throwing like feet out for a It's just disgusting watching it
happen in real time to somebody else. All right. Okay. He has
said it about Trump. Well, no, he hasn't said that. And he technically
has said if you're in the West Bank, which is Palestinian territory.
No.
Well, no. No, because he said former EFL or even former FA militants.
Okay. It is perfectly legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral.
Okay?
100%. This is not like a black and this is not a gray area. This
is black and white. Okay? It doesn't get more black and white
than >> And he's also >> which I didn't expect. >> What?
Oh,
I accidentally clicked on a dicker's vod apparently when I I
just reloaded YouTube for now. >> Number one. >> See
if anyone's streaming. >> Um, no streaming. What the >> uh
not only did he say former, but he stated her by name and she
was formerly in the military. >> Well, technically not
by name, but yes. No, it was a it was a Dickers VOD that I'd
watched uh yesterday or something. >> There's no there's
there's no talking around this, right? I mean, this is this is
crazy. Yeah. I mean, there you go. When he said someone has to
do it, talking about assassinating the president. Well, I I don't
know when he said that. I'd have to go back and see, but um yeah,
there you go. Podcaster's wife. Yeah. Uh tag Ethan. Oh, Ethan
probably already knows about this. It's not like it's a big secret
or anything like that, but um yeah. Uh let me go back. I'll see
if there's any more posts about this. and state of Palestine
is not recognized by the United States. So, wouldn't Palestinians
legally be expected to follow Israeli law? I have no idea. I
mean, it doesn't really matter, but um anyway, uh this man could
shoot human being on stream and get away with it. Yeah. And so,
what I think is crazy about this is that like this has been a
problem. I think that this has been this problem has been escalating
over time. And I think that especially ever since October 7th,
I think that Hassan has basically gotten more and more and more
extreme. And I is he facilitating terrorism in his chat? Is he
promoting terrorism? Well, it's undeniable that he promotes terrorism.
This is this is an undeniable objective fact. He puts it out
there and he says that he's 10 toes down and he supports it.
I mean like this is not Hassan isn't a terrorist but he promotes
terrorists and so why is this even
people just build up a narrative right he he supports people
who will support um anybody who's being occupied anybody who
is under undergoing a genocide that's his that's his narrative
that's his argument right it's just so lazy it's just so lazy
it's so lazy
you say
he might have honestly I'm uh I'm trying to figure out where
we're going next with this. Okay. Uh what are we doing here?
We're looking at I'm probably going to go and look at the Hassan
reacting back to him with regards to the FBI thing. Give me a
second. Give me a >> Podcasters like uh wife that participated
in these raids. The violence that the Palestinians
>> No, no, no, no, no. Sorry. This is a stupid clip. I
meant to pull up this one. Hassan reacting back to it. >> Legal
occupying force is >> This is the one we want right here.
>> Literally legal. Definitionally legal. Okay. It's just
the truth. And >> no, it's not. If somebody attacks
mine, they're going to go to jail.
>> Yeah. No, you [__] I'm talking about participation
in an illegal raid in the West Bank. Oh god. No, it's not. Yeah,
of course someone if someone were to like people legitimately
are arguing. Asmin Gold here is arguing. Well, did Hassan just
say that murder is legal in the state of California? Um, I'm
pretty sure Hassan just said murder is legal and morally right
in the state of California. I think he just said that >> Attack
line right now. Of course, they should go to jail. What kind
of idiocy is this? Oh my god.
>> Why is he telling people this? >> Why would he
be say what is wrong with you? Do you think we'll get banned
for? >> He is wrong. I know many people are not going to
like it, but he is wrong here. Why would you say that, Hassan?
Why would you say that this
at this point? I don't think so. I think that Twitch just doesn't
care. I I do. I think that Twitch is they're so so ideologically
captured by >> Yeah, Twitch is so woke. That's why they
never ban your dude. I just Oh, >> Hassan's so bad at responding
here. Hassan should just point out how stupid Asmin Gold looks
and say, "If you want to talk about this, come talk come on my
stream and talk about it." Right? That's all you got to do, right?
That's it. >> Just I I don't know if they're actually intentionally
obtuse or they're >> uh Salty McNelie, I fully support
the Kyler Maxwell memes now. I didn't support them in like the
first week after it came out. I didn't support the commentary
people in saying it. I would correct them on my stream. That's
like the whole thing, right? Yeah. Like I I didn't think that
was a good narrative. Turns out I was wrong though. I was totally
wrong. That was a great narrative. That was actually exactly
what was going on. >> This stupid Aan, he's not misreading
you by mistake. He's moving the conversation to something that
makes you look bad. Yeah, of course. I know. I understand. I
mean, or maybe he's that stupid. I don't know. He's definitely
that stupid. >> Like I I don't know what to do.
>> if Asmin Gold doesn't look at the longer context, he
is just malicious.
>> $3. Remember in Back to the Future 2 when Marty gets
the almanac back from Biff after his dad knocks him out and that
one random guy said, "I think he took his wallet." He took his
wallet. That sad mongold. I >> I don't know what you're
talking about, Ruben. Ruben, but thank you for the three. I'm
sure some people will get that and it'll be really awesome for
>> I don't He wants in on the lawsuit, I guess. So, I mean,
like he's making a direct call for violence,
>> a a direct and immediate call for violence against people
that are Americans.
That's insane. Oh my god. Yeah. Now you come to that conclusion
conclusion. Well, I mean, no, I' I've said that before. I mean,
I have. And so, yeah. Uh, make a post like with Alpha Mike. Let's
share. Yeah. I think that's something Ethan should report to
the FBI. I think if Asmin Gold won't come out and admit he was
like totally wrong on this and it's like obvious he's totally
wrong then fails the Brandenberg test even if it was exactly
how they're stating it. Sure. But uh
if he won't come out in a video he's totally wrong on this then
he's like totally malicious too. Uh what did Kyla say for the
Kyla Maxwell thing to be valid? Anyone in chat know what she
said? It's not her statements it's her lack of statements Nick.
It's her total lack of moral principle. It's her failure to act
right. She said she disavowed Desty that she sorry that she stepped
away from him professionally. I don't think there's any evidence
she did. In fact, now she's saying she's just 50/50 partners
with him in some endeavor, right? Like they're business partners
again. I don't think any of the facts on the ground have changed
at all and Kylo is just totally back with him. That's why it's
Kyla Maxwell.
>> honestly. Yeah, >> bro. This would love to see
evidence they did. So, >> I've not seen it, but other than
her
>> why does it matter being against American citizens?
Am I missing something? Yeah, I don't know. I don't know what
he's even trying to imply there. It is pretty crazy, though.
Um, it's going to get you even more lost souls uh to convince
the more jingoistic they go. Don't give them the satisfaction
or even being seemingly worked up, they get even more feral.
You've done nothing wrong. No, I know. I think he's just trying
to throw at a wall to see what sticks. Like I I I'm going to
be real like I I I think that like I mean at this point like
you have like it's domestic ter. Yeah. I mean, report what? Report
that you have a person that's on a platform that's making an
open call for violence and insinuating that one specific person
should be a victim to that. I mean, we just watched like the
Roblox, right, of uh online communities that are like in radicalized
to do random acts of violence. And here you have
>> uh this is gay, but why did Hila get mentioned in the
first place? Because Assan's saying that no matter how nice or
or normal the IDF seems, any IDF member engaging in any operations
in the West Bank is a valid target for violence. Even if it was
Ela Klein being a oo m bean secretary on that night raid, she
would have been a violent a valid target. Uh it totally maps
on. It's the most innocent version of an IDF member who's engaged
in those operations he can think of. And it's a dig at his enemies.
That's 100% valid in every possible way. And if you're too stupid
to understand that, that's fine. But like, why would I hold this
on to a bar that like nobody else meets, right? Should he just
never mention Ela? Maybe mentioning Hila in any context could
be considered bad if Hila totally removes herself from the stuff.
Says, "I don't want any part of this drama. I don't want any
part of this. I'm getting out. I'm out. I'm out." Right? If she
said that, that's fine. Is it digging Ethan? Yes. But nothing
else I said is is incorrect there. It's a dig at Ethan that fits
perfectly into what he's being said or sorry, what he's saying.
I don't know. Just seems like a dead horse getting beaten. No,
it was funny. It was >> Destiny's community actively pushing.
>> It fits into his point totally
and he is like he's correct in making the point. Fits into his
point totally and it's funny. And he's taking a dig at people
who constantly take digs at him who just said on their stream
like two days ago that he's like what? Sending nudes to minors
or something or getting nudes from minors or something and basically
called like a How in the is he in the wrong here? Are you kidding
me? Like Destiny using his community to actively come after me
in a violent way. Streamer Destiny. >> Honestly, I honestly
think you could perfectly justify attacking such IRL for statements
like this. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Wow.
Steven Kenneth Bonnel II is attempting to incite his audience
to attack Kilaman [__] in real life for arguing that
Palestinians should be allowed to defend themselves against war
criminals. breaking into their homes to kidnap them in the middle
of the night. >> You know what? I should be nicer to the
people who don't understand this. Okay, I can explain this very
kindly to any of these people. I really should be nicer to them.
I should be a lot nicer to them. Okay, that's my bad. I should
be more kind to you, I should just go, you know what? If you
want to come on the stream, you want to talk about it, I'll walk
you through it very nicely, okay? I I don't have to be an [__]
All right? Maybe you just misunderstand.
Maybe you just misunderstand. >> Honestly, I think you
could perfectly justify attacking for statements like this. People
are saying, "Destiny, this is just so far beyond the pale." It's
actually unbelievable. Pepe, say less. Put me in
cinema. Destiny, say no more. Salute. Okay, never mind. I'm reging
all this [__] cuz I was under the impression that
heritability literally just refers to general pattern observ.
Okay, Destiny. Holy [__] Does this grant me moral
authority to do it? Will Asmin Gold talk about how unacceptable
this is? Probably not considering that he himself is talking
about how this should be u like my accurate assessment of international
law in the process of an illegal raid that an occupational force
is conducting on an occupied peoples that is illegally occupied
is u what he perceives as a death threat. I hate this industry
man. It really sucks. >> By the way, I'm sure all of the
DGers are very upset that Destiny's leaning into like actually
overtly calling for violence, right? I'm sure everybody there
is very mad, right? I'm sure everybody here is very mad about
this. I'm sure if I go to DG, they'll go, "Destiny, this is a
bridge too far. You just said you could justify us on for this."
Oh, but hold on, wait, hold on, hold on, hold on. I honestly
think you could perfectly justify attacking such as on our for
statements like this. Now, if you called him on this, he would
unironically go, "You know what? But I didn't say I would. I
didn't say I do. I'm just thinking you probably could. Maybe."
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly, Als. Yeah, exactly. We can all see it. It's
just funny. It's just funny. >> Will Asmin Gold talk about
how unacceptable this is? Probably not. Considering that he himself
is talking about how this should be um like my accurate assessment
of international law in the process of an illegal raid that an
occupational force is conducting on an occupied peoples that
is illegally occupied is uh what he perceives as a death threat.
I hate this industry, man. It really sucks, >> dude. He
sounds so defeated. The song goes too far.
H song goes too far. Wow.
Crazy. Go watch the VOD. Wait, go watch what VOD. Whose VOD?
We're going to get through a lot more clips on this, guys. Don't
worry. There's like a lot of other
sounds defeated. Yeah, he does sound defeated. Dude, I hate this
place. Okay, what do we got next? We've still got We could still
probably go through more Asthma Gold stuff. I'm hoping at some
point. Is there not a point here where Asmin goal gets sent into
some food slabs in the algo? No, that's morale, right? Food shops
wants to touch kids. Proof. That's morale, bro. That's morale.
Did you see Doro's correction clip? I did. And I said Nicholas
is better than everybody. I think it's I think it's incumbent
on you to go and uh to go and explain to people like why this
lie is going around, what's going on here. Call out the people
who are lying, who are just propagating that lie, right? I think
so. I think so. But Nick is doing so much better than everybody
else that it's hard to have too much heat for him. Although,
I am kind of annoyed that he will amplify and then not un retweet
the or un unh delete his his amplification of the same narrative,
right? There's like something there that kind of annoys me, but
whatever. Whatever, dude. Whatever, man.
>> Okay. Well, we're going all across the internet. We
got all the dummies. We got them all lined up. Hassan calls for
the death of Ethan Klein's wife. Teone. Now, here's the thing.
I think Teeone sometimes knows to go look for context on clips,
right? I think he does. So, I'm interested to see if he knows
to do it here. I'm interested to see if he'll engage, if he'll
do anything like that. Could be interesting. See, there post
about it. What is this? What is this? What is this? Can the man
explain this? Comes off as incredibly unhinged to make these
statements. 4 hours ago. 30% upvoted. Deleted thread. Let's see.
Let's see. Let's see. Your comment has been posted. Uh, a comment
or post has been removed for violating rule seven. Overly harsh,
rude, or dramatic comments. Yeah, I Guys, isn't it a little too
far to call for this guy's death? Uh, you're being dramatic.
You're being dramatic and rude right now. Uh, excuse me. No,
you're just being dramatic and rude. That's it. You're just being
dramatic and rude. Hold on. I uh Do we have to do it? I might
have to do it. I'm telling Rey to hop on. Really can come hop
on. We'll talk about it. I don't know what Rey's position is
yet, but we'll check it out. Okay, I told him to hop on cuz I
just saw a tweet. Hold on. Maybe I should just respond on Twitter
real quick. Let me go respond to him on Twitter. All right, I'll
leave a reply for him. Sorry. Uh, we'll start on the techone
thing. I'm getting some caffeine. Give me two seconds. >> Hop
for the piggies. And this one, I [__] you not. If
you saw the title on the thumbnail, Hassan has called for the
death of Ethan Klein's wife. This is crazy. I have yet to see
this clip yet, but the headlines are true. Let's listen to this.
what Hassan just said live in front of 40,000. Wait, let me let
me let me be completely correct here. How many viewers? Hassan
in this live in front of 23,000
viewers. Hassan calling for the death of H3's wife. >> Matter
if they're DFLP, PFLP, or even former FATA militants. Okay. It
is perfectly legal, perfectly valid, and perfectly moral. Okay.
100%. There's no
>> Hold on. Oh, that's his music. Jesus.
gray area. This is black and white. Okay, it doesn't get more
black and white than this. >> Israel is in the wrong. Israel
is actually
a part which is a crime in and of itself. Israel is doing a genocide
in Gaza and an aparttheite in the West Bank. Two crimes in and
of itself and every every type of armed resistance against both
the settlers and also the Israeli occupying force in the West
Bank. Doesn't matter if it's your favorite podcasters like uh
wife that participate in these ratings. Doesn't >> So
because there's a war in Israel and Palestine, Hassan says it's
completely fine for you to go and Ela Klein because in her past
she was a part of the ID. >> I didn't even notice how insidious
that is. Like I'm actually having a hard time even I'm having
a hard time even hating the clipper on this. Okay, the clipper
on this one might be inspired a little bit cuz they're actually
they're just freely pointing out how so many people who comment
on this [__] are too stupid to even go and educate
themselves in any way. So many people do not understand what
fatai is. There are just a bunch of influencers who don't get
it even remotely. They don't know what fat is. They don't even
try. Right.
>> F has since has since retired had a family. migrated
to another country. >> Oh, Rodmus, if you if you haven't
caught up, uh, this is totally disingenuously clipped and it
is not what he's saying at all. And it's very obvious what he's
saying. And we're we're going to go and do some counter propaganda.
I guess you're going have to go fight propaganda on this one.
They don't even know what the West Bank is. They probably don't.
>> And has done nothing besides her required military service.
Hassan is saying that you should be allowed and it's perfectly
legal to go Ethan's wife. Yes, Hassan [__] is arguing
right now that it is legal in the state of California to go to
Bair and apparently Ethan Klein's wife. That's that's something
Hassan [__] would do. Yep. Sure.
Believable. So believable, guys.
How do these people I I purp I personally when I when I'm saying
something insane like that, I have to stop, walk back, and think
again about like what I'm trying to say, right? I have to I have
to like go and think about it because I can't okay I can't just
say something crazy like that and not like try to take a step
back and say in a vacuum is the thing I'm saying insane. Do I
really think Hassan would say that? And you have to wonder how
you get to the place where you're so brainwashed that you'd believe
somebody would make that statement like a massive streamer would
make that statement, right? But it's just it's not even remotely
there for him or Asmin Gold.
So, because Ethan Klein's wife had forced military service obligations,
he believes that you should be allowed to go kill her. >> Guys,
this is insane. This is psychotic.
>> I I'm I'm actually shocked this was even said live on
the platform.
And And the worst thing is
I don't think he's going to get banned at all. Why would he say
that? Because he's
You know what? >> People in his chat are like, "Wait, why
would that Wait, are you sure that >> No, even more than
that, he's just a horrific, horrible human being. >> How
is it disingenuously clipped, though? Are you asking me this?
The disingenuous clipping is leading the former Fata militants
part in there. I'm saying that that's left in there, right? Intentionally,
I believe. So, like, I'm saying I have a hard time hitting the
clipper. I think they might have left that in there knowing that
none of these people actually know what Fatah is and that they
think that Hassan is saying former IDF militants and they think
fat is like maybe a a division of the IDF or some right I'm saying
that's inspired from the clipper if you want to make it look
bad right but it's also cut from the context of he's watching
a documentary on the West Bank he is saying violence by Palestinians
in the West Bank and the Gaza Strip is justified against the
occupying force
that is the context that is cut from this clip.
>> I cannot imagine calling for the death of someone's
wife in front of your radicalized audience saying it's perfectly
legal and perfectly moral to go kill Ethan's wife.
Guys, he literally just had a call to action telling his entire
audience to kill Ethan's wife and said it's completely fine.
>> Dude, these people are so stupid. They're so stupid.
My My life is I I feel like I must be in the Truman Show and
there's like somebody who is just slowly making it clear that
everybody who I like everybody who's like online is they're like
we're going to put this guy in a career and we're going to make
the dumbest human beings totally successful in that career. Yep.
Yep. Now watch watch him react to these people say the dumbest
things possible and then we're going to give them money and and
we're not going to give him money. We're going to give them money.
I'm like I'm in I'm in the Truman Show. Okay. It's crazy. This
is crazy.
>> Do Do we understand how dangerous this >> Fata
is Oh god, I don't want to [__] this up. Is it that
Fata is the what was it? A part what the PLO was a part of. Fata
is like a I I want to say a political organization right in in
Palestine that like it was made up of multiple parties and the
PLO was like the biggest party in Fatah,
right? That's my that's my guess. Let's check it out. Officially
the Palestinian National Liberation Movement uh is a Palestin
Palestinian nationalist and social democratic party. It is the
largest faction of the confederated multi-arty Palestinian liber
Oh, other way around. It is the largest party in the PLO. The
PLO is the organization and Fata is the largest party of which
Yaser Arafat and now um Makmoud the boss are the leaders of were
the leaders of. Got it. Got it. Other way around me other way
around. Well, at least I knew it was Palestinian. Okay, at least
I'm not that much of a dummy. >> Guys, the worst thing
is this was from 4 days ago.
He >> That's how you know it didn't happen, by the way.
That's how you know it didn't happen. Cuz so many people listen
to this and were like that. And trust me, Hassan's got hate watchers.
Okay, son's got tons of hate watchers. So many people listen
to this and said there's nothing wrong with that statement. That's
how you know it's trumped up. That's how you know that you should
look deeper. That it was 4 days ago. He never got banned for
this. This was four days
Encouraging his entire audience to go a streamer's wife
when I got banned for two weeks for calling Frogan fat and denims
a both of which they are. I I just want to watch Teone cover
the broader context and see what happened. Okay. Nicholas responded
to Teone. I think was it a Techone quote tweet? I think he quote
tweeted techone and said, "Hey, just so you know, this is like
the actual context here, right?" And it's so sad that they have
to go, "Well, this is the context." And like maybe he's a little
reckless, dude. How How about you were a little reckless in propagating
this narrative without even looking at all you just go retweet
you just go quote tweet and say, "Oh, it's so bad that this is
happening. Oh, online sphere is crazy right now." How about you
were a little reckless? Okay,
now people are calling for Hassan's death and you participate
in that. >> I I I'm I'm actually shocked. I hope to God
there's some background music this [__] video because
there's going to be a lot of dead air because I'm shocked. I
I I I I genuinely cannot believe I genuinely cannot believe this
is on this >> I have no idea. It's just sad. It's
>> This is crazy. Oh my god. >> You know what? What's
his name? Is it uh
Vani? The guy who runs kick. Okay, that guy's Muslim. Can we
get that guy? I need I need an oiler. Okay. I need somebody to
fund. We We have to We have to fix the internet. Okay. Oh, what's
his name? Is it Ton? His last name is Bjani. Oh, Bjan. Bjan Tyroni.
God damn it. I got his name totally backwards. My bad. My bad.
Come on, man. You got to start You got to start funding this
whole sphere of the internet cuz we need we need to we need some
truth in the world, okay? We need somebody who's going to actually
go and evaluate like this and actually care about just telling
the truth. I need someone I need someone to step up, okay? This
is crazy. >> So, would it be completely fine for me to
say Hassan as a terrorist supporter, it's perfectly legal and
it's so black and white for you to be killed because you support
terrorism?
>> Are we Are we crazy here? This is nuts by the US government.
>> Well, guys, I I I bet you nothing will come from this.
I don't know if you guys are shocked. >> He's already gotten
to the point where they wouldn't even punish Assad for this.
It's so clear he did it. They won't even punish him for it. >> I
am. But that's disgusting. Here's Ethan Klein's reaction to Hassan
calling for the death of his wife. And we're just going to read
it. So if I started >> "Oh, nice. We already have. We have
the Ethan Klein reaction built in. Let's >> Like Hassan
is a propagandist and therefore a legit military target, which
I do not believe. Everyone is going to be okay with that. This
is the fourth time a leftist Twitch streamer has explicitly called
for me or Ela's death. Nobody has been reprehended for these
death threats by Twitch. Not once. For comparison on YouTube.
>> Reprehended. Reprimanded. Reprehended. >> Bad
empanada played an FBS game where you play as a and murder Israeli.
>> You know what's [__] up? It's up. Okay,
I just saw a Ralph reaction in chat. It's [__] up
when Ethan Ralph is having more informed, more accurate takes
than 99% of Twitch and YouTube streamers. Okay,
that's the world we live in right now where Ethan Ralph is the
voice of reason. That's the world >> he simulated
in a game and as a result caught a week-long suspension. He hasn't
wished death on either of us on YouTube since then since he knows
there are repercussions for making death threats on YouTube.
Twitch, what the are we doing?
Genuinely, Twitch, what the are we doing, dude? This is this
this is this like I try to make like >> Oh, wait, wait,
wait. That thread we were pulling up from before. I'm just going
to go look at it real quick. Comment from it. This is about uh
Destiny calling for Hassan's death, saying you could make that
argument. And we said how people would try to defend it, right?
What exactly is unhinged about this? He's saying he feels like
someone could use whatever it is as a justification for violence.
He's not calling for violence or suggesting someone should.
Uh-huh. Okay. By the way, with Destiny, unfortunately for Destiny,
I've watched him go through stuff like this and I've watched
this done to him enough that I know that he knows exactly what's
happening here, right? That he knows that like Hassan's being
taken out of context. He probably has looked at the broader context
himself, right? And he knows exactly what's happening. He knows
exactly the lies. He is malicious. He is totally malicious when
he does this. Destiny and Dan know they don't care. Basically,
yes. They're just totally maliciously lying. Totally writing
fanfiction. Okay. creative writing exercise. It's It's crazy
>> even happening. >> I think this is why you're
seeing, by the way, whoops, wrong video. We were going back to
the Techone video. This is why you're seeing the brain drain
from DG. Why it's like all dumb people and why they can't do
like ops the same way they used to. It's just all stupid people
now. Just got here. Better not be any dog whistling going on
or I'm going to tell Willie Max show. Thank you. Max already
did his dog whistling spray. You missed it. Okay, Max was here.
He did his dog whistling and now he's moved on. Isn't this that
exactly one to one to what they claim Hassan said? He didn't
say people should kill a Klein. Uh sure that could be one to
one with what uh they said as well. >> Dude, it's all >> content
out of these clips. >> It's goofed, man. >> And like
make it funny, but like this is beyond psychotic.
>> I didn't even cover the whole comment. Sorry. Hold on.
I got to back up. I didn't cover the whole comment. Whoops. Uh
no, bro. He's not calling for violence or suggesting someone
should minus two. By the way, this person is making a justification
for violence so broad that it would also apply to them. No, I
don't think that is a call for violence at all. Specifically
mentioned Sissad, bro. Nah, it was so broad. Are you literally
dude minus six, dude? There are only like total morons left in
this community. There's this is insane. This is like DG's been
like operation paperclipipped. Like all of the all of the remotely
intelligent people who were there are just gone. It's wild. content
out of these clips and like make it
>> But like this is beyond psychotic. This this transcends
a funny meme or a joke I can make.
these are people's lives that streamers are calling for the ending
of.
You
You cannot. Now what? Now once again, if you want to tell someone
to >> This is so lazy. This is so lazy. This is so lazy.
Disgusting. With Teone, I know he's just too lazy to actually
go and look into this at all. Right. >> Elves, that's not
a threat. That's a suggestion.
You can't tell your chat to go kill someone. It's legal and it's
the good thing to do. Like, that's >> Yeah. No, I guarantee
you if he actually got in any conversation about this with anybody,
okay, his response would be, "Wait, what's wrong with that?"
Uh, roll it back. Roll it back. >> That's a suggestion.
You can't tell your chat to go kill someone. It's legal and it's
the good thing to do.
>> Yeah. What's that? Seems pretty correct to me. I What
do you disagree? What did you disagree with that? What do you
disagree with that? I just said you can't tell people not to
kill other people. What? What else? I said what what else do
you disagree with there? What do you can't disagree with me on
that? Like, bro, are you serious? Is this chat living in the
West Bank, dude? >> Like that's that's that is crazy. >> And
they fully believe it seems like Sorry, Techone. Oh, man. I unfortunately
after this, I'm not even going to continue on with this stuff
for all that long. After this, we're going to go watch the podcast
again. Okay. So, we go watch Dan to tell go watch Dan tell these
guys. Okay. Uh Teone,
Nuaku. It wasn't Asmin. Asmin wasn't on there, was he? It was
Tone, Nux, and one other guy. Who was who's the third guy with
Dan? In any case, okay, where he goes and tells them just lie.
Just lie. Just lie. Just lie. Just lie. Because that's what we're
watching it play out in real time. Don't be honest, cuz they
wouldn't be honest with you. Just lie. Just lie. Just make everything
lies.
Jesus. Okay. Well, moving forward from that, please leave a comment
on how you feel about that. Also like, comment, subscribe, and
turn the bell on for all notifications if you're here because
I will be following this and I will also be messaging Twitch
directly about this clip uh immediately after this. Um, thank
you for being here. By the way, we have Asold's response to Idubbb's
political analysis on them. And let's get into it. >> Uh,
I I don't really I don't know what to say about that. I really
don't. Uh, but uh, yeah,
totally misunderstood it. And, uh, it is what it is, right? He's
high on something. I have no idea. I think that this is this
is my opinion. I >> is this sorry this is Idubbbz responding
to the clip itself >> that Ian is in a position where
>> all he does is parrot Hassan's talking points because
that's all he knows what to do. He can't go live without a script.
He just hears what Hassan says and then says the exact same thing.
He can't do this freestyle. He can't react to clips freestyle.
He doesn't know what to say unless he's gotten his daddy's permission
first. >> Let me think of a good way to say this. Like
cuz I
>> that's just for like Techto and Nux Taku to either one
of them to make that point. I put them in the same group by the
way. That's crazy. >> Said I I like Idubbbz, but I >> I
used to like Idubbbz. I no longer have any respect for the guy
because why would I? >> I think that he's in over his head
with this stuff. I think >> anybody who would backstab
his best friend like that for a couple of views to promote an
event of his is a guaranteed piece of [__] Now I
like Idubbbz without Ana and I do believe that Ana completely
ruined him alongside his son and co because Idubbbz >> such
an easy cool
so lazy >> but in 2025
>> guys Idubbbz is like a but it's actually just all Ana
and Isa totally ruined this guy. Okay. Anisa totally ruined this
guy. And uh yeah, I'm just I'm saying women suck, guys. That's
all I'm saying. Okay. Women suck. Actually, >> Idubbbz
has never been more of a his entire life. I >> think that
you've lared a lot as like having these viewpoints and being
around these groups of people. And I think that you've taken
on a lot of these traits, but you haven't really done enough
time to like really look at where these values are coming from
and why people are saying these things. That's what it, >> bro.
That would take a lot of time. Okay. All it took, all it would
have taken for Asmin Gold and Techone to not look like total
here is to go find that timestamp, right? Like I did before I
streamed. Okay. Go take the 5, 10, 15 minutes it takes to find
that time stamp, run it back, watch the whole thing, and then
come to an understanding, right?
And he's he's criticizing Idubbbz for saying, "Well, you don't
understand where their values come from." I don't think I don't
think Asminold does at all. I don't think he understands about
this
and he you're saying oh Idubbbz go go read you know go read for
a couple months figure out the theory and then come and talk
about this bro go watch a clip for 2 minutes and then come back
and talk about it okay don't tell somebody to go take six months
when you can't take two minutes to educate yourself okay seems
like to me and he needs to stay in his lane yeah he doesn't understand
much yeah and again like I I
>> no this didn't happen there's nobody I don't believe
this I I don't believe anybody could have watched the context,
seen what was actually going on, and still been upset. I don't
believe that. Show me anybody doing that. Hutch. I don't want
to comment on Hutch right now. Okay.
>> Maybe he just misunderstood me, but it seems like because
he didn't understand like the core root of what I was really
trying to get at here. Um, you know, how much of this are you
like really like is this really something you believe in or is
this just something that you're pushing and you're saying you're
believing in it? because it certainly seems pretty inauthentic
uh for somebody to make that comparison.
>> A lot of things that Asmin go Hold on. I got to go find
I got to go find the Idubbbz clip. Okay, I got to go find >> can
seem harsh if you don't understand where he's coming from. But
if you actually look into what it is he's actually saying, why
it is he's saying that, and not just have a gut reaction, things
will make a lot more sense. It really, really, really will. Now,
a lot of people could say, "Well, can't you say the same thing
about Assan?" I want you to tell me how you can justify saying
the Houthies deserve a Nobel Peace Prize when they're killing
children and bombing airports. And if the same guy is, how can
you justify Hassan making a direct call to action to H3's wife?
That's >> a direct call to action. Okay, >> that
is [__] crazy. All right, here we go. Let's keep
going. I don't know what the context of this is. >> No,
he's not even calling her still a valid target, Kger. Uh, but
you weren't watching her. you go back to the beginning and watch
it again, which I love when Hassan and Destiny fight. It's the
best. It It's the best. Keep it keep it between those two. It's
great. >> Further than Destiny,
Destiny, who has spent every waking moment in the last like seven
years at this point actively >> Yeah, I sorry. I just The
only thing I got wrong, Space Ghost, was just the uh I couldn't
remember if his PLO above and Feta was a membership member of
the PLO or if the PLO was a member of Fata. I just I I inverted
that. They're marginal left figures, people like myself. >> You
know what's crazy? By Hassan's definition of best fest, uh, Denims
is also afining
is someone who pers someone for and Denims was literally >> No,
that's not what he means. That's not what he means at all. >> On
her knees begging Destiny for But he was too aloof to understand
that. And with how many nudes that Hassan has received from his
fans, you know for sure he was begging for that [__]
as well, which by the way, send nudes to a streamer, you're >> uh
with endless.
>> God, I was so Oh man,
you know what? I I'm just going to continue, okay? >> There
were two people, okay, who came out like six months ago. There
two people five, six months ago, had a couple conversations about
this and like the geniuses they are, okay, said, "Oh, this whole
thing, this is rotten root and stem. There's like this whole
section of the internet that's totally rotted. Okay.
Holy [__] I could just I man I see so much. I'm like
totally vague posting. Never mind. >> Pieces of harassment,
ridiculous smear campaigns, stuff and um >> very goofy.
hasn't really been successful for his own career
>> but it has been successful in I think undermining
uh the the broader reception of the left by a larger uh by a
larger audience that already wasn't going to be super charitable
to the left anyway. And in that process, I think instead of converting
a lot of these like right-wingers and into liberals who vote
for the Democratic party, I think he ends up pushing them to
the max. >> I think this is the first time Hassan has ever
said that right-wingers and are different things.
So good on him, man. Character development. I thought everybody
who voted for Donald Trump is a so good for him for making that
distinction. Though in my opinion, it was probably >> Similarist
position of anti-communism and anti-ocialism, which is always
going to be not fascism. >> And the greatest example of
this is of course his son. >> Oh Jesus. He's going to go
into this. I think I'm uh I think I'm still just totally dodging
this topic, guys. Sorry. Although I will say Drew Pav still like
a total total weirdo. Okay. But I think I'm mostly dodging this
topic. This is going to be it. All right. We watched the Eel
Klein thing. That's totally fake.
What is this from? This from eight hours ago. All right. Hold
on. Did we get any response from Tee to the Nicholas Dioro correction?
Do we had this correction on the the Techone quote tweet? Did
we get uh anything on this from Tech? Have we seen a Techone
update? We get anything to do with that? Techone. Teone.
Oh, right. I forgot about this. Nice progress, bro. I'm I'm good
with that. Oh, he just retweets the uh lying version. Cool, cool,
cool, cool. They don't walk back. They should just be laughed
out of the room completely. Man, there needs to be there needs
to be some better way to get these people to come in and talk.
I'm trying to think of like how you do it. I think it's got to
be Twitter spaces. I think so. I think we got to start doing
Twitter spaces on these topics and just let people come in and
like say, "Yeah, I'm I'm arguing that Hassan did not even remotely
call for violence against uh Hila Klein. Go ahead, hop in." Right.
YouTube hit pieces. Well, yeah, but I can't engage in that one.
Okay. I can't engage in that one, unfortunately. But we got to
we got to be able to roll with this [__] Okay. Okay.
We got the techone criticisms
obviously just goofy as you seem like you were taking this personally
almost. No, I'm just uh engaged
and emotional for like entertainment value. No, I'm I mean, if
you if you think the emotions are affecting something, go ahead.
But I'm totally I I just I think this is offensive. I find it
personally offensive. Okay, so you know what? You're actually
right. You're actually totally right. I am taking this personally.
It is personally offensive to me that I feel the need to go and
look into this clip when I see it and none of these people do.
It's personally offensive to me that none of these these people
do the same job I do, right? They go live, they talk about the
news, they put no work in, they just lie through their teeth,
and then they get financially rewarded for it. So, you know what?
I do take it personally. It is actually a personal attack on
me. It is all about me. These people, okay,
it's actually disgusting. Also, they're attacking my fellow cabal
member, Hassan [__] Okay. >> I was just at
his house recently. >> Donated $3. You are a good man for
avoiding that topic. But something tells me that if you had a
kid, they wouldn't avoid it. >> Oh, they wouldn't. No,
they're total scum. Yeah. But here's the thing. The reason I
avoid it is not because I don't want to hurt people. Like I it
has nothing to do with like protecting the people I dislike or
think are scum, right? It has to do with there's somebody who
is adjacent who has not done any wrong and I'm not going to hurt
them by covering it. And I do believe if you are engaging with
a minor on the internet who is like whatever whatever if you
were engaging with Destiny's kid on the internet in terms of
politics right now, I do believe you are like probably harming
them more than anything. Okay. A lot of people doing it to get
back at Destiny. Very disgusting behavior. I'm not interested.
Nobody actually cares about this kid's I just want one person
to care about this kid's wellbeing. You know what I'm saying?
Just one. Just one. Oh, hold on. What did Loner Box say here?
I got a loner box. Sweet. If Ela Klein was doing her secretary
job underneath a hospital, would she still be a valid target?
Underneath a hospital in Raala? Probably not in a way that like
hurts civilians. That's pretty easy, right? I get what he I guess.
Do I get what he's doing here? Not totally.
Guess I don't totally get it. Uh yes, evil Johnny Bravo. I was
already getting uncomfortable with the Twitch uh the Twitch anti-semitism
stuff, right? So, I mean, Queen were sitting here going like,
"Dan, you're crashing out right now. Dan, you're making [__]
up. Dan, that's not how that goes. Dan, you're making up, right?"
I was pushing back against that whole thing the whole time they
were running it. Or I'd tell them like, "Hey, go in this direction
where there's like actually smoke. Don't Don't try to push this
bull that you're pushing. Okay, go over in this direction." I
don't I don't actually know. Would she still be a valid target?
I don't I actually don't understand the inversion. I I'm sure
I could understand it. I'm just not seeing it. Somebody explain
the inversion here. The hospital strike joke. Well, I'm guess
I'm getting that it's like a collateral damage thing, but I don't
think they're advocating for collateral damage in the West Bank.
What were the directions that Dan didn't explore? I'm just saying
no, no, no. There's nothing like that spray. I'm saying on stream
we're like, Dan, this is like this is thin. This is like tenuous,
right? Like I I argued with him about the IP ban thing, how like
that I thought he was saying that wrong. I was trying to keep
things straight mostly for his sake. I was like, "Hey, if you
just lie about this stuff, it's not going to go anywhere. You
can't just lie about it. It's like going to actually totally
up your movement. Zing
zing. Actually, I just don't understand the tweet here, but maybe
um I just might not understand it. That's fine. There was another
loader box tweet. Was it relevant? Was the raid Hila went on
in Raala necessary for Israel's security? Uh hard to say. Probably
the fact that no one Oh, hold on. Maybe there is a little more
going on here. Okay, hold on. Hila went on an illegal raid in
the West Bank, which was not part of her job. You dumb. She chose
to go on the raid. Her job was just a desk job, not to go on
illegal raids in the West Bank. Again, which she willingly chose
to do to go on despite it not being a part of her job, dumbass.
Why do you think the IDF raid in the West Bank is automatically
illegal? I know the actual legal issue here is far more complex
and disputed than you're going to. Yeah, see, you went you went
in on the um you went in on the legal illegal thing. Uh I don't
Dude, it's like it's almost impossible for anybody who's not
like an international law scholar to say like exactly what would
and wouldn't be like legal here. Yes, she admits it was an illegal
raid. Okay. She might have said so in the clip. I'm just saying
I don't know the legality of like the raids or doing violence
back. I'm not totally sure morally. I think if if these Israelis
come in and just constantly like kidnap people at night, right?
I personally am sitting here like, well, I'm sorry. Like I think
these people can defend themselves. It's an illegal occupation.
I think they can defend themselves. Why do you think it's automatically
illegal? I know the actual Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Was the raid
Ela went on in Ramala necessary for Hila for Israel's security?
And then he responds with the fact that no one knows the answer
to this question is really where this discussion begins and ends
with what we know now. The raid could have been legal or illegal.
Anyone trying to argue one way or uh one way or the other without
more information is a charlatan. I think you are a charlatan
if you don't call out the clear lies that are being propagated
on behalf of like right. You have to you have to call people
out who are just lying. And I I believed no what no matter what
lonerbox would admit that there is no direct call for violence.
There's no blanket call for violence against Hila Klein here.
That doesn't exist. Right? So we can we can totally quibble and
that's why I'm being careful. I'm like dude I for all I know
Hassan's totally lying about the legality of this. But the legality
doesn't matter.
Right? If actual people are using a hospital to Hassan even then
it's still not a valid target. I think that's what Loterbox is
making fun of.
Yes. Because of the collateral damage. Right. Do you think Hassan
would be okay with um with like civilians
dying to go after Hila Klein? I don't think so. I don't I just
don't I don't think it's like a joke that maps on. I just don't
see it as mapping on almost at all. She said, quote, "We weren't
supposed to be there, so we had to not get caught." And she means
by the commander. Oh, I mean, that seems pretty open and closed,
doesn't it? Should we go get this clip? Link link a time stamp
soap box. Let's watch it. Let's watch it right now. If she says
she can't be there, we weren't supposed to be there. We couldn't
get caught. I know we watched it earlier. I'm saying link the
time stamp again. I'm just I'm not going to go dig through the
clip while I'm on stream. That's all. I So, I didn't hear her
say that exact verbiage. Okay. I was listening to other parts
of it. I didn't get that exact verbiage, but that would be to
me pretty conclusive. Oh, I think it makes you lean like what
8020 9010 that it was an illegal raid versus illegal raid. Isn't
she saying uh she might be saying she's not allowed to go? Wasn't
allowed to. Oh,
wait. That's possible. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's possible. I in
fact that's way more in line with my remembrance of Adelfilo
that like she couldn't get caught 9010 legal. Uh wait I don't
know if Israel occupying the West Bank is even legal to begin
with. Is it under international law? Isn't the whole thing illegal
under international law? Anyway, I don't think that's actually
I don't think any of this the legality of it the rate the legality
of the raid. I don't think almost any of that matters in my opinion.
I'm talking about like morally this this occupying force coming
in at night that goes and like kidnaps people, raids their houses
at night. I think there's no reason to engage in night raids
unless there's somebody you can't get any other way. And when
Ela says they go every night, I just don't believe that there
are terrorists in the West Bank or in Raala who you can only
get at night. Uh that such that you can only go at night every
single day of the week or something, right? Even though she's
probably
being hyperbolic like that's that's the whole thing. Oh, we did
these all the time is what she's saying, right? We did them all
the time.
uh and we like went through these houses. We would go through
the houses. We would like pull people out, right? We would find
guns in their houses and pull them out. They're terrorists. Okay.
Anyway, so I just I think the illegality is like that's not even
like the interesting part of this. It's like, yeah, I think I
think Hassan's broad point I don't think Lerbox would really
disagree with. If we just if we just strip out like him talking
about the legal aspect just morally do you think people in in
Ramala have the right to defend themselves against night raids
from the IDF? The Jeep did get up. Yes, it did. I sent you the
clip the chatter's referencing. Okay, we'll uh we'll keep watching
though. I'm going to keep going around. Okay, we have the loner
box tweet. There's a what is there a Hutch?
Who did Hutch respond to that I have the thing for? Give me a
second. Uh uh uh. Oh, is Hutch and Wick? I got a Hutch and Wick
thread on this. Dude, there's a lot of stuff on Twitter that's
just goofy as [__] on this. To take a jab at Ela
like that after CPS in the skulls is really disgusting behavior.
Do these people have any decency left in them at all, bro? Uh-huh.
Uh, night raids from what I've seen. Hold on. I thought night
raids were almost universally more likely to go bad. Wait, evil
Johnny Bravo. I thought night raids were far more likely to go
bad. such that like some places basically like outlaw them. Am
I crazy?
>> What? What's up, Really? How's it going? >> Going
well, young one. You wish to speak over the Ethan Klein situation?